what up guys it is Tuesday and that
means it's the great area with myself
Sarah Garvey and the woman who should be
now done for terrorism for dropping
bombs okay on U.S soil okay it is just
funny things thank you Sarah I like that
intro yeah listen Pearl I just want to
say before we get started
are you are you now wanted woman what do
you mean you wanted by the the alphabet
services for dropping bombs on Uso
because you went over to the U.S a
couple of weeks ago and you dropped some
bombs girl yeah you know I I didn't want
it aren't I damn you're you must be
wanted right I I must be
[Laughter]
right over to you Bill okay guys
um today we have a sponsor
okay so um a major airline has privacy
rights activists disappear oh wait sorry
let me do it again a major airline has
privacy rights activists disappointed
after a recent data breach turned out to
be a gold mine for hackers this affected
customers and employees of the airline
they had their social security numbers
drivers license numbers and other
personally identifiable information
stolen in a matter of days several other
airlines in recent years have had
similar data breaches making me wonder
if my data has ever been stolen as well
that's why I signed up with virtual
Shield one virtual Shield ones identity
protection feature scans 700 billion
data elements for suspicious activities
associated with your name bank account
and other personally identifiable
information to alert you after a data
breach it also comes with unlimited VPN
access and advanced VPN features
including malware and ad blocking try
virtual Shield ones risk free for 30
days by clicking the link in the
description box below and after entering
your details you'll have instantaneous
access to all Security benefits virtual
Shield one offers yeah so I learned that
I had a lot of passwords leaked so that
was that was a fun a fun way to start my
week okay so um before we get started on
the show today's topic is are
traditional relationships dead
um we've got some guests here but before
we even get started tell them ah if you
have watched
two or more how many two
of our videos and you have not
subscribed uh-huh then we have what
Pearl beef what have we got beef exactly
so you better get doing that right now
okay so we have a panel of guess here
and we're gonna start talking about
whether or not traditional relationships
are dead so if we could just go around
and introduce ourselves let's tell your
name your age
uh relationship status and a fun fact
about you
we'll start over there with you my
friend
yo my name is China the magnum's voice
is about the I don't know the fifth time
I've been on here shout out to Sarah
always wanted to get on the shoulder
comments been telling us we should get
on the show together
um 38 um I got me a sweet one
fun fact fun fact
uh we'll just repeat the fact my
greatest advice to women is currently at
almost at seven million views so that's
viral so shout out to everyone that's
been sharing it yeah it's good vibes
okay next
hi my name is Alea I'm known as call me
lay X and I am you know an actress and I
enjoy speaking and you know
just really go with the flow I like to
have a good conversation howdy 22 years
old okay
next hi I'm Emily just Emily music
um we're doing Asia
I just turned 30.
um and a fun fact fun fact about me um
and relationship stays oh relationship
I'm single
um and fun fact I'm a Pampers Baby so
I'm a Johnson's baby that's a fun fact
what does that mean I'm like one of the
Johnson's babies or from the adverts or
the little babies that they use I'm one
of them but you were unlike the
packaging
[Music]
all right so wait I have to do a couple
announcements of course yeah I gotta
finish sorry I'm getting back into it
it's okay you've been gone for too long
oh my God yeah he's getting excited he's
too excited to start the shower okay
guys a couple announcements before we
start the first is that we have two
different clips channels the first being
just pearly clips and the second being
Pearl daily I believe we're almost at
150 or 200k on the clips channel so make
sure you guys go subscribe to that on
top of that guys we are going to be
members only for the chat today so make
sure you sign up for the five dollar
tier that lets you be a part of the chat
and future chats going forward our
second tier you get to be a part of our
Discord and and you get our Vlogs third
tier you connect with me on social media
and fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month I really
recommend this guys I had 65 roughly 70
million views this month you wanna know
how I did it sign up for that call I
don't give away my info for free on top
of that go follow my Instagram just dot
pearly things you have to type out the
whole thing because I am Shadow banned
on Instagram I believe I'm at 65 70k so
go go follow there
um I'm gonna learn how to take better
pictures this month that's what my
manager told me so go follow that
um
on top of that
um
thank you guys for 500k like that was
that was awesome thank you for the
support oh it's a million yeah I haven't
gotten to say it since I've been um back
but honestly guys the support means so
much to me I am in shock because I'm
already almost at 600k and it's been a
week so thank all of you for that and ah
there's one more thing I was gonna say
but I don't remember what it was oh okay
well it's gone well we can get started
anyway we can get started we can get
started I'll do it at the ad break oh oh
wait I do remember the highest Super
Chat of the show you're going to be the
sponsor for next show so if you send
like a really high Super Chat what we're
gonna do is we're gonna bring out a
whiteboard or maybe a something here and
we're going to write out your super chat
so it's like an incentive whoever's the
sponsor next show if you have like a
funny message you want to put on the
wall or something nice
nice right so let's get started
traditional relationships are they dead
or are they still alive when we say
traditional
let I want to find out because that
people have their different views of
what the traditional relationship is
um
can I ask what people's views of a
traditional relationship is to them
jump in anybody jump in the woman the
nurturer and the man the protector and
provider
are those dead yeah
undeniably so I say really yeah I think
um
I think it's difficult for men to want
to provide because of
city girls
um and things are like
um and that's understandable and I think
women are we have rights and we are
independent and we can do what men can
do these days so there's just like it's
like a
what's the opposite of retracting
you think we can do what men can do
well I mean I can pay my own way and I
can put I've been protecting myself in
all my relationships so in that sense
yeah well I'm just thinking if someone
breaks into your apartment what do you
call a man
well no I don't you're gonna go down the
side of the bed and and shake and
prepare myself because I'm single I
don't have a man because I had to get
rid of him because he wasn't protecting
me
but
well he wasn't protecting you what do
you mean he wasn't making sure that I'm
safe in all areas mentally
financially oh yeah so he didn't make
enough we didn't make anything I was
supporting him and and happily oh god oh
you're dating bomb
yeah
I mean I think it's and it's not wrong
I'm not saying that you know that it's
it's wrong that men are like that
because
I can understand it times have changed
we can't deny that it's not men don't go
out and work in Coal Mines anymore and
do you know what I mean so it's
understandable but it's very difficult
for both men and women I feel
what do you what do you think
traditional relationships are they dead
no I don't think they're dead like
everyone has their own take on
traditional relationships I mean what
was he saying about like the woman like
basically staying at home not staying at
home but being the nurturer being like
the emotional and what not one I feel
like yes because men they don't really
show emotion like that
yeah they don't want to because they're
scared getting finessed and um
true and like nowadays it's just so hard
to know what's true
it's hard to know it's true like
someone can say they're in love with you
but how do you know they're really in
love with you
you don't think Love's a choice
it's like their actions
you don't think so in some relationships
yes but I think in you know in certain
relationships you don't have a choice
it's like a force you feel forced well I
think that's like long term how it used
to be you don't even like because
like you think in a 30 40 year marriage
you're gonna really feel love every day
of course like some years you're
probably not going to like them that
much true what do you think
yeah I agree um so I'll just listen you
know what it was I want to listen to
what you guys had to say before I said
um
sorry okay so yeah so
no I believe traditional relationships
do exist um I still believe they still
happen but if you talk about the niche
what tradition traditional relationships
and were initially no that is dead so
you're not really gonna well tons of you
getting a woman that's a virgin right
it's it's unlikely
um depending on the age depends on
that's not true no no I'm just saying
I'm just saying the chances in the
dating world in the dating world what
percent of women over the age okay the
average age of first marriage in the UK
what age do you think it is over 30.
that's 31. what percent of 31 year olds
are virgins as women
probably five good is not that high yeah
Thirty Thirty One you're telling me this
girl's waited half her life cat I don't
believe a single girl that tells me
she's over
26 I'll give you and it's still a virgin
I don't believe you women are losing
their virginity are like 14 now like
yeah yeah it's because of social media
all these cardi B songs you know yeah so
yeah so sorry yeah so yeah so um so
traditional in a sense of the world yeah
that fundamental what tradition was
based on oh yeah that's gone but there's
there's something else that we could
consider as traditional goals so what's
the one we say if you've got her body
counts over below five or something that
makes her someone so the new traditional
woman is a woman with the body count
below five no I'm just saying you can't
change you can't change the definitions
of Virgin 100 but what I mean in a sense
of um
so
like existing and or as part of a
tradition long established that's the
definition of traditional yeah so I
don't think so in order for you to have
a traditional relation traditional man
or your traditional woman so the thing
where a lot of women want to have the
cake and eat it they want to live single
lives while they've got a man and still
want to access some of the benefits of
of being a tradition so for you um Emily
for what you said in regards to the guy
that you you was with he just wasn't a
good guy he was a bum so if you're with
a guy and you're having to pay for him
if he can't offer you any protection
then really and truly what is what what
is the need for him there's no need for
you to have him there but that doesn't
mean that traditional men don't exist in
traditional world don't exist and if you
make money this thing where women now
make money that that was money should
never be a reason that you cannot still
have a man follow his leadership
um and now this thing when where yes you
can go out and earn and you could even
earn more than the man but that does not
mean that his role has diminished now
because a man's role was never just
about money and Finance it shouldn't it
shouldn't but sometimes it does because
of the toxic masculinity and the the
toxic masculinity doesn't exist it
doesn't exist that's the term let's
forget that term then but I'm saying I
agree with you it shouldn't be that way
but unfortunately it is because of
insert whichever word you want
doesn't allow it I think it's it's
hypergamy women want to date across and
up I think it's natural to women but
I don't think money is the end-all
be-all nowadays but has anyone here been
in a traditional relationship that they
would class as traditional or in a
traditional relationship
traditional
um
like it to the point
um I guess where the lady like Emily was
saying the lady is the nurturer at home
and the guy is the protective provider
goes out makes the money and the woman's
like a stay-at-home mom I had a taste
of it funnily enough in college I had to
take
and it
did a job and I was at dance school but
it was that really nice coming home I'm
doing the dinner he's getting in the
bath and you know what I mean so I've
had a taste but with men with over the
age
18 no
oh really why do you think that is
uh my choices first and foremost
um
I wish I knew what happened to the guy
in college yeah why don't you why'd you
keep that one he's the one that got away
kind of because he kissed a girl once in
our early stages and I left him
and I regret it because what I've been
through with my exes after him like he's
a good kiss that's nothing I'm like I
kicked myself I'll be honest with you
how old were you uh this was from 16 to
19. you're 16. yeah do you ever think
like
women he did another girl advise you to
leave
like your friends okay no because I
always I hear a lot of times girls will
leave when they when he cheats but then
they don't find someone they love more
and so it's like you know it's it's like
is it is it better you know
traditional relationship you've been in
one
China
um no because I'll be married then for
me a traditional relationship ends in
marriage okay so if it doesn't matter if
she plays the part for a year or two
years if it doesn't end in actual
marriage then it doesn't matter so it's
like I think sometimes people look back
in relationships and they'll be like oh
yeah oh my ex did this for me or my ex
did that for me but I'll be like if you
didn't end in marriage then what does it
matter what x did for you because they
didn't actually do the ultimate thing
that would show you the traditional man
or woman
um do you believe that relationships
today have to end a marriage yeah for
them to be successful well my thing is
this is is
is
if a man doesn't want to marry you then
he hasn't got good intention for you
long term that's what I believe you
don't think so when men women are paid
to leave the contract it's such a bad
contract nowadays where women are
incentivized to leave so like honestly I
think men have good reason not to want
to get married nowadays no I understand
that but if we if we talk about the
family home and we know about it we know
about all the statistics and and you
know being a two-parent home and having
a father that's in the home like like if
you really care about your family as a
man you would do certain things we also
know that there's certain certain
protections that be marriage does for
your wife as well and does for your
family so I just think ultimately
um if someone loves you that much
they're going to want to make the
ultimate sacrifice and commitment to you
commit with marriage yeah so let me live
with a with a 50 40 divorce rate where
she can leave take half and take your
kids you don't you don't think that some
men want traditional outcomes but
marriage just isn't on the table for
them I I believe marriage is on table
for everybody but it just someone it
depends what you're willing to risk and
a lot these men you had to put risk to
get in the place so to make it easier
though to make it easier right um I want
to like do like a little thought
experiment right so you have a holiday
destination
and it's your best holiday destination
it's the place that you've always wanted
to go and you can get it you can go
there all expenses paid
right
however
when you get on a plane you have a 50
chance of getting to the holiday
destination
are you gonna get on a plane
yeah plain analogy aren't good for me I
don't like planes anyway all right
because it doesn't give you the outcome
that makes sense to you right but are
you going to get on if it's 50 50 chance
to get to that your best destination
that you've always thought about and
you've always cared about and you've
always loved but you've got a 50 50
chance of getting in would you get on a
plane oh okay I'll give another one if
there was uh yeah you haven't answered
that one yeah bro no you know what it is
because you're using a plain analogy and
I just don't really like planes but if
if there's something that I really
wanted that it was 50 50 chance that I
was still gonna go and get it and that's
the type of man I am so the risk is
worth it
that's disingenuous you know damn no you
would not no because no because I'm not
talking about the plane because you're
talking about uh you're talking about
losing my life money is not losing yeah
because the thing is no but the thing is
with marriage you can marriage marriage
can lead to a lot of men commit a lot of
men are committing suicide after being
you know taken to the cleaners by women
their children being taken their house
being taken their cars being taken and
it's one thing when you're a young guy
but when you're you're 50 55 you're
tired and she can she can leave you and
take all of your money yeah to
understand like
you don't come from that that's not your
what you've seen growing up that's not
what I've seen growing up yes I'm aware
it happens but if that's not what I've
seen growing up then why would I be
scared of it like for me for this thing
that you put this thing you're saying I
understand it and I don't know because
it's a different generation of women
right like we remember like the women of
that generation were wives yeah but I I
understand that as well but I'm not
gonna say all the women that in this
generation are not wives like I think it
makes it quite easy to find the wives
when everyone is clearly not wise right
so if you're if you meet a woman you can
tell the good women from not the women
that's why they don't they don't hang
around for a lot they get snapped up so
quickly because once you discover oh my
God she's a good one guys are literally
doing the most there's some girls like
like I said before another show that
they don't have to do anything men just
do everything you know why these aren't
the women that are arguing and beefing
you over this over the stupidest things
they literally good women and and
there's not enough of these women out
there so when we spot them we wipe them
and we lock them down
um and these are types of women that get
married not the topic but good women
still go or stray some women are all the
dice and this is we can say as women you
know you know ladies ladies we can all
think of one girl that's an absolute
hoar used to be a hoe and she could hide
it but yeah like girls girls are a roll
of the dice and I think men think
they're a lot smarter than they are and
that's that's what I'm saying like why
like I you don't think that some guys
wouldn't be interested in marriage
because of the contract incentivizes
women to make poor decisions yeah no
from a legal perspective if I was a guy
I wouldn't do it I fully understand what
people are saying I fully understand
what you're saying I fully understand
what you're saying but at the same time
that's what that's for me that's the
union that's yours yeah I'm not gonna
have no baby mother like that's not
something I would have like I would have
a woman that's my wife like to
understand like like to me okay cool to
have a baby mother all it takes for you
to do is have sex with someone and just
and that's it and the guitar is going to
be the thing is I don't disagree with
you yeah but what I'm saying is that for
me the reason why I'm asking that is
traditional relationships dead is
because we're living in a different time
okay and I think adapting to the time
may be what human beings need to do and
I think sometimes we're trying to hang
on to the old ways and bring them into
the new and we can clearly see in this
Society it's a new time yeah but it's a
really new time yeah but in the west I
was gonna say look look I live in the
west spot I was growing up an African
upbringing right so there's there's no
reason why for all of us to lose our
morals and lose our heads it becomes
very dangerous when you get put into a
society or place and all of a sudden now
you start getting new new um new ideas
on how relationships would be this is
why people just decide they can be a
giraffe today and everyone's gonna say
you can be a giraffe like I I like like
I am I'm quite aware of where I am and
what country I'm in and and this even
some of the things I've said you get
people saying oh my gosh you're so all
of the things they'll try to lay me for
having it for man having a voice but I
understand it so I'm not gonna start to
change my beliefs based upon where I am
no I'm going to be the same person and I
believe there's going to be people
because my my sisters were raised as
wives for other people's sister for
other people's husbands so ultimately
other people are raising their their
daughters
um and their sisters to be husbands um
to be wise for me so there's ah sorry
I'm not saying wives don't exist I'm not
saying there's no wives in 2022 I'm
saying legally as a man if I was a guy I
would not want to sign that contract
and I don't think it's like does he love
her enough does he not it's it's it's a
contract that you are paid to leave I
think you can still do a ceremony with a
ring in your church whatever but legally
why on Earth would you do that as a guy
but I I honestly if you really
understand the legality of it I honestly
think it's not smart I think it's dumb I
don't know if I was following what you
were saying right right because I don't
know if I heard like
contradiction right can I ask you would
you say that you're in a traditional
relationship right now with your sweet
one
um traditional well no I'm not married
so yeah I heard you say that but would
you forget marriage like a traditional
relationship well well she listens to me
um she respects what I say hi in my
chest
see the reason why that hurts your chest
is because you was with a man that
didn't do anything for you so oh my God
my alarm and did a lot for me but that's
that's not why it hurt my chest no but
I'm saying like see when a woman listens
to you because she trusts you in
leadership she understands that this guy
I'm with um he's not going to do me he's
not going to steer me down the wrong
path um he's a he's a strong leader
that's why she listens to me so I'm not
sure doesn't listen to me because she
hasn't got a mind of course you can do
whatever she wants I do not control any
woman but when you're with the right man
you were actually fall into your
feminine and let him lead and do certain
things because you trust in his
leadership and a lot of times when women
go my chest is because they haven't
experienced that oh it's because that's
what you led with but that I've heard
what you've LED with your leadership no
but what I mean is what I'm trying to
say is see even the the shock in it
that's not what girls do you want to be
with a guy that you trust his leadership
absolutely like that you would listen to
No no absolutely absolutely
yeah so why does it hurt your chest
because it was what he led with no
because that she listens to me is that a
problem
because to me that's ideal
you don't think so
it's ideal to have a guy okay let me
explain go ahead I want to be able to
listen to someone right I have ears I'm
going to listen but perhaps if what you
were to say is
she can trust me or something like that
or she left see the problem she lets me
lead her it was just the phrase and the
fact that that's what you led with in
terms of right but that's but that's
what submission is right if you believe
in submission that's trusting him even
when you don't want to yeah I think it's
for me it was the um choice of words and
the fact that it came with that was that
was the first that was what he left but
that's the thing about you know women
like men when men speak they just speak
women hear things like oh my God you
could have said it differently yeah but
we can't deny that there is there is
meaning behind people's choice of words
so so that's that's it's just it is what
it is what I get is it I'm really tired
of women always telling me how to speak
like do you know how do you know how
much control no no no no you literally
just did no I didn't you literally just
didn't tell you how to speak I told you
what what would have been but I'm not
telling you how to speak you go you go
ahead speaking of course I want to speak
how I want to speak but you're already
telling me the way I'm speaking is a
problem in it because you couldn't you
couldn't yeah you're all right so it
comes down to you not me I haven't said
I haven't said anything disrespectful I
didn't say you haven't I'm talking about
how I'm talking about so don't turn it
into no I'm not that's not me no no okay
you literally just said you had a
problem I know what I said but we're not
going to confuse what I said and make it
okay okay so let me just speak right
this is this is something that tends to
happen with a lot of women right men
speak direct I'm a very direct speaker I
will say what I need to say I said that
um she listens to me all of a sudden you
had negative connotation with the word
listen so she listened to me because she
trusted my leadership they shouldn't I
shouldn't have to I know I understand
the word listen yeah so you're just
misunderstanding clarified can I can I
can I finish because we'll just keep
doing this yeah thank you okay no I
haven't misquoted you you said something
so I need to follow up on what you said
because because what you're doing is
what women always do to us men so we
speak direct we're articulate we say
something then you want to say you
should say it in a way like this we are
not women see the problem is the types
of men that you are attracted to
ultimately speaking away where or or
acting a way where you may not like
um but when I'm speaking I'm never
speaking in a derogatory way about women
I'm never disrespecting women I'm just
simply saying that if you trust in the
man's leadership and ultimate submission
is showing is is love and when and when
you love a man you're not going to
question certain things so if it shocks
you to say oh um
um she listens to me it just says to me
that ultimately the types of men that
you've dealt with haven't spoken like
this or when they have your pushback
yeah yeah definitely I definitely think
I'm a good listener and I crave someone
that I can listen to right like when we
were speaking about the one that you
know was you called a bum I love that
um I couldn't listen to him he couldn't
lead and I crave that because I want
someone that I can feel secure with and
be like yeah you've got so then why why
choose somebody who you can't do that
with because I don't see it at first I
don't understand it he didn't have a job
um no no no he had a job he's a creative
so he he owns if you meet him and walk
into his office you'll think wow this
guy's got it together but that's not the
case but then you were still supporting
him I was supporting him yeah so the job
the job wasn't making money no because
it's like it's um
it's not a facade it's just you know
there's there's a job one month and
that's month nothing you might get a
massive sorry he's like who's contract
yeah exactly how long did you support
them for uh six months and then and then
you cut it off I couldn't do it anymore
yeah that's not too long that's not that
bad yeah some girls come out and they
say like three years
there was a girl on here I was like I I
done a course on what is it um on music
because he was a rapper and I was gonna
be like this producer I'm like yeah you
like really invested in that bomb do you
know what I'm saying this ain't build
the bomb
I think that's a problem with now as
well because of course Instagrams are
like people's CVS and stuff and it's so
easy to portray yourself one way and
then when you go to their house yeah but
who do you think is more deceptive men
or women on Instagram I think both oh
come on I think women are specifically
and like lifestyle but guys with like
you know money girl you think I think 90
of guys have ass Instagrams like they
have like 500 followers with three
pictures most guys
though it's not even that you see men
like I I tend to find that a lot of men
they don't know how to take pictures so
you might look at their Instagram and be
like oh my god wow he's so not my type
you see him in person and it's a whole
different story I fall in love with
men's comments on Instagram like if I if
I see you think in a certain way and
like I don't even know what you look
like you could just be a Grace Circle
and I'd be like
now you wouldn't fall in love with mine
when you would hate me
so when it comes to traditional
relationships right
for the past year right I've thought
about this a new relationship contract
and I'm saying pearls held it already
and
um I've said it a few times
but I think
that men and women because of the times
we're living in should have rolling
contracts for relationships meaning the
two of you should sit down stipulate
what you want in a relationship and have
a rolling contract however long you guys
want it could be a year two years six
months whatever and then after that time
you get to renew it but within that
contract you guys both get to stipulate
exactly what you want out of the
relationship
what'd you guys think of that bad idea
okay why because how now I'm throwing up
contracts with my girl this is not this
is the worst idea ever you drop
contracts for for marriage yeah I know
but in listen and that doesn't work so
tell me 50 50 50. so put if you're
drawing a contract in a relationship and
a boyfriend a girlfriend scenario it's
not that deep so basically everyone is
single until you're married like that
everyone's up for game the only way I
know that you not to approach you if
you've got a ring on your finger so when
someone says oh I've got a man
yeah but we're living in a time now
marriage doesn't matter people people
are having
the reason why I'm coming up with it is
because my thing is
there has to be a solution to the times
that we're living in okay and so we
can't keep trying to fit a square peg
into a round hole if it doesn't fit now
I know everybody keeps talking about
marriage marriage marriage marriage
marriage but when you look at the
statistics it's not working so I'm the
type of person who sees something sees
us not working and offers a different a
different perspective now it may not be
the right perspective but what everybody
can see is that this thing is not
working so if it isn't working
what's the new model so it's marriage
without marriage
it's marriage without matter yeah it
could say that it's marriage yeah so
then we should just do what we're doing
already now because end of the day
there's no way it's a little bit more
now
well on the other side it Advocates more
for the man that's that's basically what
Tara is saying but then I mean you even
nowadays you have one in four marriages
that are sexless so men get married
thinking they're gonna have sex and they
don't even have sex and she puts on a
lot of weight after she gets the ring
and then you know she leaves you and
takes half yeah and then within the
contract you'd say you know you wouldn't
be able to gain a certain amount of
weight you wouldn't be able to know him
inside or not why not I will why not
you have to have a certain amount of sex
it's up to you you because a lot of like
Pearl was saying a lot of men get into
relationships
a quarter of marriages are sexless so
why would I get into an into a
relationship knowing I'm not gonna get
sex as a man that's one of the things
that we love and it's interesting
because I understand like what you're
saying because you know I I do in a way
because I I do like I think marriage
like it was a good thing in my life
right like for my parents were married
most people I know were married but the
thing is like the more I learn about the
contracts I'm like I could I I could see
a guy being very devoted to a girl being
with her for 10 plus years and just no
ring because it's a bad contract to sign
so you're willing to be a baby mama then
no no no no but I think legally you know
but this is what I'm saying I don't need
it legally but I I think like not being
having a part of the government that's
fine no but if you can't if it's not you
get married in your church
okay okay cool like me personally okay
so if we get married in the village in
back home
um it's going to be similar to what
you're trying to say right but you're
still legally married to each other do
you understand what I'm trying to say to
you I think what we're trying to do now
is we're trying to create new
definitions for what marriage is
supposed to be and what relationship if
that's the case then and then just do
what you're doing you don't have to
actually I mean have a contract I think
they're just trying to find a solution
for a bad deal no right now the contract
is a bad deal for men so just be single
and just do your thing that's what a lot
of guys are doing yeah but that's cool
that's what I'm saying I'm saying so a
lot of guys are doing that but marriage
nowadays like If we're honest with
ourselves if we're actually honest with
the society in which we live in marriage
is a joke and when I say that it's a
joke do you know why because marriage is
a TV show
Love is Blind 90 Day Fiance
Married at First Sight marriage has
become entertainment
it's not there's no sanctity in it
anymore so when the same women that are
sitting down to watch Married at First
Sight and love is blind and 90 Day
Fiance the same woman saying oh yeah I
want to get married you're literally
watching marriage as a TV show it's not
there's no sanctity to it anymore and so
that people can literally say okay I've
got 90 days to get a visa to to marry
this woman that's not marriage yeah but
so I don't think like yeah that's
marriage is a joke so so if we're gonna
say marriage is a joke based upon Night
and Day Fiance like now man you need to
stop watching no it's based off of the
numbers it's based off of one in four
marriages are sexless one and four the
average length of a first marriage is
seven years and it gets smaller and
smaller based on how many marriages
there are it's based on the fact that
the men are paid women are paid to leave
and take half and take your children
that's why it's a joke it's not it's not
based off of a TV show yeah so I hear
what you guys are saying I hear what
you're saying but
um now
seriously you think about it because it
doesn't feel nice to you yeah that's the
thing it doesn't feel it doesn't feel
nice and I understand where you are
because I was there at one point too no
no I could listen I haven't gotten to my
age or not had any kids because I don't
because I can't come on like I've got in
here because I don't want to have a baby
mom's and I could easily have like my
friends have baby mums but I've seen
what it's done most of these kids that
are growing up doing the madness on the
on the road now they they're coming from
single parent homes
so even this thing over you're talking
about if it's not marriage it's not
going it's gonna be the same thing that
we're seeing right now so when we're
trying to go out now and say you know
what actually let's not get married
let's write a contract why are you gonna
keep to the contract is because the
contract is more um it's more individual
whereas a marriage uh contract is more
broad like you said men when it comes to
marriage they get the short end of the
stick if the marriage breaks down like I
said I said 50 50 before you didn't like
the um the airplane analogy but that's
what it is like marriage goes to a train
what a train yeah yeah it's not a train
is it a plane is an automobile because
everything that you every knowledge that
you give towards America includes death
and I
a lot of guys commit suicide because
think about think about put yourself in
those guys shoes you work for 20 30
years you're still young you lost
everything tomorrow you could still
build it back yeah but right but I'm
saying this guy's 55. his wife leaves
him if he has children that are still
under the age of 18 she takes the kids
he and she is paid to take them and give
him less time and then he has to start
from scratch at 55.
yeah he took an l yeah good for women
though let's remember that women do have
like a hard time in in divorces
sometimes it's not I know I know
you know girl how
how you've built the man up to what he
has yeah
no no why don't we take credit for men's
success if your guy was successful he
was going to do it with or without you
we didn't build anyone else we didn't
build anyone up my dad is a top one
percent earner I grew up around these
top one percent five percent man I
promise to God they love their wives
their wives are there for them but they
would have been rich with or without
them
so if you built this man right yeah if
you're building this manner
I'm just using it
so if you if you built this man yeah and
you're saying this man is only
successful because you built him yeah
and and and imagine that no I don't like
that that's not what all right but let's
just say that that let's just say that's
the Pavilion psychology of certain women
right why is it now if women feel that
they've invested into a man and built
him up why are they the ones that 80 of
the time that are filing for divorce
because if I if I if I invested in
something educated
why leave it I can't talk because every
every relationship's different I don't
know what's going on in the particular
you know I mean in those num in those
statistics I don't know what happened so
I can't really I can't really do you
know what I mean but I know that yeah I
just wanted to just remember we're not
it's not just oh the man's depressed and
you know lost every there's a lot of
women that end up in the gutter after
after divorce and men that leave their
wives as well not just women that up and
take everything well even even if they
do leave they're legally protected men
aren't so even even if a guy does you
know trade you for the younger model or
whatever yeah it needs to be changed I
agree on that yeah so would you say that
in today's society men are more
traditional or women are more
traditional men men
oh okay yeah at least they try to be
they want you know
why do you think that is so because no
music no a lot of the time it's it's
with
So within with all the new age feminism
and yeah some of the music some of the
cult some of the things popular culture
that they follow
um women don't feel as if in actual fact
it seems to be a negative connotation
attached to tradition being traditional
so even when I said she listens to me
all of a sudden that created a feeling
of something in the chest of until we
explained it but it still created
something submission it seems to be some
nasty word as soon as you say oh she
would submit women hate that word
because submission for them it means
that they can't leave the house they
can't do anything they can't have any
friends they can't wear it I'm not
saying for you I'm saying majority of
women no I just saw your face but I'm
just just just making it clear but women
don't like the word submission but for
us men we it's not a negative word you
understand it just means that you're
Trust on our leadership so so yeah yeah
I want more more men to be made of stuff
that we can trust your leadership
because I think a lot of men in this
Society are leading from a very weird
place and I get it like it's different
people say weird what do you mean like I
just feel like they're just
they're just so um
cautious and whatnot and they don't
trust that you know if they meet a good
woman and that she is just she does she
does mean well she doesn't have bad
intentions on whatnot they have this
like elephant in their brain kind of
thing that doesn't allow them to sorry
sorry
um
what was it that you asked me what did I
mean by yeah would that you said they're
weird like
weird no quote me what I said you said
they had this elephant in their brain
before that I said this weird oh I think
they don't trust good women
yeah like it's difficult for them to
to be to allow them in there's always
like this Barrett this kind of barrier
of distrust do you want to hear an
interesting stat yeah I'd love to
um did you know that
under 30 one in three men are sexless
they haven't or they're either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
men under 30 one in three are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year where when where everybody yeah did
they ask you this is the statistics a
lot of times like when girls will say um
like something like those guys need to
be like they don't want to let us in
like kind of kind of a similar like it's
the tough guy doesn't want to let a good
woman in like you know I don't want to
sorry not disrespect I've just done a
lot of these shows they're talking about
the 20 of men that women want but most
guys are they're down they haven't had
sex in a year one out of three six I
mean like the no they're they're down to
commit I promise to God you kind of if
there's a guy if you've been a Texas in
a year and a girl wants to come into you
you're ready to wipe her yeah because
you want that feeling you want to feel
that feeling again so I think that like
be that being said some guys will settle
for less just to get that feeling yeah
yeah yeah like you've got to remember
like a lot of guys will just settle for
what they can get so it seems sometimes
for you women that are pretty as well
quite hard for you to understand that
men don't get sex because you're
thinking about the top 20 of guys that
you're thinking about but when you next
time walk into a shop and the Tesco's or
you go into
um into Footlocker JD Sports wherever it
is just look at those guys that are
stacking the shows look at those guys
the guys you never see those are these
are the guys that are not getting
anything yeah no no no because um these
are the guys are not that are not
getting any any attention so for me it
it really just comes down to a woman's
choice because it's just the guys you
choose you're missing all of the good
all of the all of the guys which are not
on your radar potentially could be guys
that could work for you but you keep
looking at these 20 of guys and these
are the guys if you looked in your
friends if you looked in your DMs it's
not just you it's everyone it's it's
literally everyone because if if you're
single right that means the guys that
you want don't want you otherwise you'd
be with someone I could be with someone
every day
yeah but the thing is you don't want
them which that's the point like anyone
that's single it's the guys you want
don't want you anyone yeah you know
otherwise you'd be with someone yeah but
what's wrong with all the guys that
what's wrong with the 80 of guys those
other guys what's wrong with them what
would you mean like the guys you don't
see what's wrong with them
no I love no swag I love a lazy eye the
buck
can I give me a give me an example
can I can I see someone on Instagram you
don't have to we don't have to put them
on the screen I just want to see if I
actually I won't like my ex yeah show me
show me one show me one we won't put
them on the screen or anything well
what type of oh hey we got
a new face all right bring your mic
closer to you
um hang on let me help you out one sec
let me do it
let me show you
I had a whole folder
won't you yeah why have you still got
photos of your ex because I made him a
um photo album of all of our time
together for his for Valentine's last
year so to print out all the photos I
had to make a folder I've probably done
so he didn't delete it I think I have
because I can't find it yeah oh no I
didn't wow wow
what do you guys okay actually question
for the girls do you guys keep pictures
of your ex no I need to clear out my
hole okay so she does
I know I got a better one no no I'll
give it out yes
oh wait she's muted I think
can you talk yeah yeah okay yeah that's
good yeah yeah I do do that but I've
started deleting them now though because
it's that little jump or the Fright that
you get when you see it it's not not fun
is it YouTube pictures no I definitely
delete the pictures because it's so
toxic like why are you reminding
yourself yeah of the person that is no
longer in your life yeah I think it's
more Snapchat memories it's not like I
have an album with them like from
Valentine's Day
I do a scrub after I'm like I can't
because it's Snapchat it's that memory
that's the problem that's it you might
just look at his picture one day and be
like oh my God I wonder who he's with
right now what he's doing I'll be honest
Pearl yeah as a man yeah when you get
with a girl this and this is I'm gonna
put this out to all the guys out there
when you get with a girl you have to be
ready to understand that it's probably
at least five to ten maybe even more
that I've got pictures and videos of
your girl on their phone like like so if
you think about old yeah
we're getting the uh the evidence yeah
so if you think about all the girls that
send picture that girl he is not ugly
someone
no but that's because girls only find
five to twenty percent of men attractive
women women find 80. he's not I'd give
him like I give him five six that's what
I guess let's not oh you're captain man
your captain your captain yeah yeah he
gets girls he gets girls he gets girls
you don't think five six yeah
not a bad dude
like women more so or they're trying to
sleep with you so like if the guy's
trying to sleep with you he'll be like
ah now he ain't [ __ ] and girls find 80
of men unattractive eighty percent
interesting 55 roughly percent of women
attractive you don't why would why is
that interesting to you you don't think
that goes like
guys that
other girls like you know girls like
guys or other girls like yeah they they
because it's a competition
I don't know because I don't I don't
think I'd go for the girls that the guys
that other girls like there's a certain
thing that I like about a man so so the
thing that you sort of got like a
certain way some girls you don't think
most girls will if they know they can
keep him
like like if a girl could let's let's if
this is an extreme example but Drake how
many girls are lined up to date Drake
nobody's thinking oh he has too many
girls around her yeah I guess yeah and
but if girl and most girls if they
thought they could keep him and retain
him they would hook up with Drake yeah
for sure yeah but the thing is like a
lot of girls know you'll be one of many
yeah
they're okay with that women women that
have a man of that state of Drake status
or whatever status it is they don't mind
being one of many
because they because they know the deal
because they know that other girls like
him yeah but that yeah that's part of
his crop that's being an artist that
that's the kind of hat you have to put
on your audience or your fans will like
you but you're one person is so if we if
we now bring it to the quote-unquote
real world it happens here too so when
women in the average woman is looking at
men she's looking for that top 20 guy
that when we ask women what type of man
do you like what does he need to have
what does he need to have what does he
have to look like women tend to choose
men in the top 20 percent
so if if 80 of women or majority of
women are choosing that top 20 of men
hmm
how many options can change isn't it
because what makes them the top 20 is uh
collection of things right and those
things can change those things are
attractive to women oh okay so so
they're attractive to women so those is
that why the relationship's broken down
then because they're going for the 20
and then [ __ ] check stuff because I I
don't know because I'm just saying if
those top 20 of men have 80 of women to
choose from so you girls are all going
full of numbers you girls are all going
for 20 of men so if if if 100 of women
are going for 20 of men who has the
options here so you women yeah no I get
exactly what you're saying but so you
could easily pick so the thing about
women is you you go you women are not
honest you don't pick the men that women
other women don't find attractive and
and you don't pick the men that other
women don't want so there's loads of men
when you think about how many guys are
out there you could easily pick one of
these guys and they would worship your
feet they would just be so happy yes
that's what I want no but you don't you
don't but you don't know
you know you don't no you don't you
don't because if you did right now
you've been married listen you'll be
married just called off an engagement
right
Revelations yes that's what I'm saying
don't get confused like my the the nice
guy the sweet guy the guy that looks
after his mum the guy that doesn't have
a lot of money I want to love you
actually I have a question was it always
that way so you said you're the nice guy
the sweet guy has it always been that
way no the guy that I told you that he
kissed another girl he was like the cool
guy like super super tall like yeah got
all the swag when would you say that
switched where you were looking for when
did you start looking for the nice guy
uh well uh sorry that's difficult that
guy that I just explained he came about
because he saved me from a very bad guy
who was a fugly ugly
so my type has like always been like I I
don't know I'm attracted to like
uh the the not the not um uh typically
or stereotypically beautiful men he was
cute the one you just showed so when
when you say you called off an
engagement
yeah so he was going to engage he was
going to propose one day like people let
it slip and then I kept on hinting like
I don't think it's the right time it's
not the right time it's not the right
time yeah okay and then he didn't like
the Ring's there the Ring's still
sitting in hand Gardens like after a
while like I just realized that it
wasn't gonna work so why because there's
just too much going on right yeah two
too much going on
was it was he a good guy
I wasn't a good guy
so then why would you accept the ring
then it doesn't make anything I didn't
accept I know but I'm saying I called it
off I know at the point of us going to
like look at rings I thought it would
work and then the realization kicked in
so I didn't allow myself to you what
what you sound like to me is you sound
like you've dated Bad Boys you've been
attracted to Bad Boys not not the ones
that would take you down the aisle and
at some point you realize actually I
need to change what I'm doing yeah
that's what I just certain okay so so
but initially you're given so this is
what women do right you spend you spend
your 20s to the point when you're in the
30s chasing the wrong types of men then
once you get to your 30s you realize
actually I shouldn't be doing this right
and you've you've been chasing off Chad
and Tyrone and then your options start
to diminish and at 30 you're like okay
what the hell have I done but in reality
there would be men you're pretty woman
there'd be men that would have taken you
up that would have happily done this but
you'd aired them you literally did not
see them and the reason why you didn't I
was loyal to crap yeah no but so but the
thing is the whole story generalizer
isn't it it's what women know but it's
like you're telling me something I
already know so I'm trying I'm letting
you land no but she's agreeing so
basically the reason why I'm saying this
is because I've we've done we've done
this show we speak to women like if you
use your 20s and you end up in your 30s
and you do not have a man you've had
from at least 17 18 you had about 12
years for you to lock it down if you
didn't it's not because you didn't meet
any good men it's because you literally
outweighed your options and now you end
up at 30 years old and now you're
competing for women in their 20s with
the men that you would want so then so
then and this is what happens with men
in their 30s and 40s right
that is when they become more
established and that is when they become
a little bit more attractive
um you know most millionaires don't
become millionaires until they're like
30 late 30s early 40s sometimes 45 and
so the men that are that have watched
the women right they've watched women
curb them I don't want them eyes are
geek guys of this these are that I don't
like him they've watched that throughout
their 20s and then they've established
themselves and they're watching now the
same women who didn't give them any time
now like oh my God I I want those type
of guys in their lives
not me love yeah that's what they think
they're like not me because when it was
time when I was kind of showing you
exactly who I was and being a good guy
and I could be a good guy you wanted the
fogs on the street that would get your
door kicked in at four o'clock in the
morning yeah I've never I've never
wanted that personally that's never been
my entail thing and I don't think that I
think there are a lot of women that do
go through that process and they waste
time you go what's cool what everybody
says is the in thing or the good looking
guy or whatever but I think it's about
choices that I think you decide what
kind of life you want to have some
people go for the whole looks and they
have to be attracted to their partner
some people I think it's down to your
love language and what you like about a
person you don't think that younger
women in general tend to date more bad
boys than older women
in general
we have to be honestly be honest be
honest hey come on there's a stereotype
for a reason the crazy high school
boyfriend yeah I know it's a thing but I
don't think it's across the board I
think there's a certain type of person
that goes no and I understand that but
the thing is like the average age of
first marriage in the UK is 31. and this
is just general feedback we're getting
from men where they're saying we're
tired of these girls have been run
through by the bad boys in their 20s and
the 30s they take me yeah right and it's
I'm not saying every single woman not
every girl does that before they become
born-again virgins and they go to church
you know they fight they find God then
they say oh my God I'm I've got two baby
babies for these crazy baby fathers now
and I'm just gonna be a Christian so I
really hate that song like seriously
this whole ball again virgin thing even
the thing even when you're saying you
can get surgery you cannot erase the
amount of things that were put inside of
you it's like for for us men it's quite
it's not a strong amount of things
does anyone here Believe In Born Again
urgent no ghosts believe in it because
they keep saying
I'm a born-again virgin thank you very
much I'm telling you everything from
months I don't think anyone actually
believes it they might believe a guy
away which that's kind of I just think
like we always said like what use is it
yeah of running up like and what tends
to happen is you girls end up running up
your body count between your teens to
your 20s and your late 30s in your 30s
then you actually decide that I should
want to get with a man what got you what
good use is 10 20 30 bodies that gonna
come to your husband they don't actually
there's no use at all in actual fact you
come here with more damage and more and
um more distress for men that's why when
you meet new women so they tend to be
like I've got trust issues but none of
these trust issues came for me I just
met you but that's what we're talking
about today men like people do that as
well because there's lots of
generalization going on here and I think
people do that if you've had something
in the past some people carry from their
past relationship this person did this
to me so they see that signing you they
assume but I think we need to be a bit
more open with
trauma everyone's got things every
everything
you're giving excuses for what you did
there's no reason why if you meet me I
need to start being open to your trauma
no one asks you to do it no wait hold on
wait hold on no one asked you to deal
with guys that are going to give you
trauma now you expect me to be a to be
some type of therapist I'm the man
that's not my job as a to be a therapist
to fix guys that you shouldn't have got
within the first place I think it's
quite you're putting things on to men
that men don't actually need to deal
with I'm just supposed to be a good man
that I don't need to be your therapist
and to fix why you why this guy did this
to you and did that I mean you're
sounding like somebody that's
experienced some really toxic women
because that's no because seriously
because it's coming it's coming across
that way because
I'm alive just come and sat here if you
know I tried to catch him what the
subject was but there's a bear
aggression in where you in the way he's
not aggressive he's just being honest so
what he's saying what he's saying is
that like why should the men of the
future have to pay for your past so if
you if you had and I'm not saying you
did I know not all girls did but this is
just a common thing that men tell me and
then like if you had toxic boyfriend and
toxic X bad boy bad boy bad boy and then
you get in this new relationship and you
dump all of that onto the new guy why
does he have to deal with that yeah no
one should have to deal with that
however
you come with your own things as well
everyone comes with their own things I
feel like it's about how people unpack
it I think once you you know what those
things are it's not to go to the new
person that you're seeing oh this has
happened to me and you better not do
this to me that's what I mean it's about
everybody has their things so my thing
is this right it gets to me when women
automatically when a man speaks you
start trying to put all this aggression
all these types of things it's not it's
not that please we need to stop this
because it's it's a tactic that women
use all the time especially on here it's
a shame and shame attached as soon as a
man speaks about something you start
talking about aggression and all these
types of things we need to really to
stop it because that's not what's going
on here but I have to I have to pull it
up because I always say listen to
people's words yeah listen to my words
don't listen to the tone because what
tends to happen is you use the tone and
you used to use the tone to to take away
from the actual message the actual point
so um yeah like there's no aggression
here there's no animosity there's
nothing but literally what I'm saying is
women tend to go and do this and we have
experienced this and as men were trying
to speak and tell you about experiences
and we speak in a way that men speak
whenever we we do was shame for it
that's a natural response for you right
I think it's important you know when
you're talking about women that get run
through by Bad Boys and whatnot what not
I think it's important to remember that
there are women that choose those people
like I have a ex-friend and that was her
thing like she wants the hood boy she
wants the gangster she wants the trapper
and then there's women that never see
that part of them and fall in
like get become attracted to like the
sensitivity that they may see in a man
but then he turns out to be he's
controller yeah
women
know we know we know deep down like I
just don't buy it when girls say oh I
was Bamboozled one day no you work come
on let me ask you when you said since it
does does do sensitive guys
attract
um women
do sensitive men attract women generally
yeah one one day me and you might
actually sit down with my ex that I
ended in court with and yeah yeah super
super abusive it was horrible and he
turned out to be a lovely guy now with
friends but your friends
yes I am because yeah I'm a quality
woman who overstands like the trauma
that people have been through and
understand why certain things happen and
help them to progress and stop
perpetuate a negative Cycles but anyway
he I I fell for him based on a fight
that happened on a bus and his care to
the little boy and the old man that were
like caught up in it is what made me
look back and then start a conversation
with him I had no idea he was a bad boy
he was a super like chubby Asian boy
like like nerdy looking whatever
whatever and it was after months of
really like sweet conversations and
whatnot what not there was no inkling
there was no red flag that this could be
a bad guy
green flags yeah that would show me that
he's a lover which is very common in
abusive men so don't you think so
someone who's too emotional yeah is more
likely to be an abuser yeah and that's
something that I now identify after the
years because they don't know how to
control their emotions so I think it's
really important that we don't kind of
oh you knew because
so it was about six months you said
before he started to show signs uh the
first like proper proper abuse was after
like nine months after nine months and
then how long did it go on for that for
three years for three years and then you
took him to court no uh police officer
drove past as he punched me into a bush
uh undercover police officer drove past
they jumped out and took him they didn't
need me because they witnessed it um so
so but this is where I don't understand
you say you didn't know but you were he
wasn't abusive for nine months and then
you knew for three and you I was a child
and that's why I've been through so much
therapy to make sure that I don't how
old were you I was that's not because
no no like let's not
yeah because if because the reason why
you said he was a child so we need to
know how old I'm saying it would win so
when someone says what stage you stayed
yeah I didn't know I didn't we're not
doing that but the the point is that
doesn't sound honest because you did
know if you stayed longer you stayed for
three years you were there I I knew I'm
saying how I became his girlfriend
before me becoming his girlfriend the
courting the initial period there were
no signs it was after I was his
girlfriend I was his then every he was
relaxed do you understand I was with no
I'm just I was with you yeah until you
until you said oh I was young and I
asked you how old you was and you won't
tell me see that's that's how
disingenuous to me because the rest of
the because like I said to Sarah I would
love if we could not have a comments
no this came about from me suggesting uh
uh talk with him present do you
understand so all the disenges so do you
think that as an abuser as you're saying
that he is he would he actually say
yes I wanna I was an abuser and this is
why
I don't think
yeah obviously I'd have to ask it but
I'm just saying because you're saying
you want to sit down and like yeah I
think it would be
interested and important because when I
hear people speak in a certain way I
think it can be quite dangerous because
think of all the women or women
think of all the women or men that might
be in a situation or whatever and when
you feel like your chastise oh you knew
deal with it like no that's not the case
there are people we didn't say I didn't
say deal with it I know you didn't sorry
I shouldn't have added that in there but
for someone that has you know been in a
situation where they have
just dealt with it when someone says oh
you knew you knew you should I mean oh
but you stayed for three years I think
it's important can you see how that
looks to to the outside like if we look
at you and say like for instance if I'm
coming home for three years and
someone's as soon as I walk in the door
someone's punching me in my face there's
lots of things about that yeah but I'm
just saying I was I was I was
um living by myself I had got a stayed
uh like squatting I'd done like living
in a foster home like I was I was not in
touch with my immediate family at that
point
there's a lot yeah there's a lot to
consider for you to be able to
understand that I don't really think
it's appropriate to unpack here and now
but if we use our
um if we think a little bit you know so
so I don't think it's fair to start
something and then and then not give us
the full story and then when we tried to
speak about he said it's not fair to
unpack it so what I would say is this
end of the day is you still pick that
guy you chose to be with that guy for
three years no matter what wherever it
was used to chose to make a decision do
you have any brothers yes did you tell
your brothers no so okay once again so
you had men in your family that could
have dealt with this scenario but you
chose not to go and do it hold on wait
hold on a second hold on a second hold
on a second because I got three sisters
yeah yeah and my sisters would know any
type of man that disrespects them that I
would get the call you chose not to call
your brothers you chose to put yourself
in something for three years and then
now when you come on here you also said
you was young I asked you how old you
was you don't want to live I don't need
to okay but that lets me know you wasn't
that's not the point
no because that lets me know you wasn't
young and using it as a Cocker bro I
just said it would invite him no but no
so so we don't so I don't know I'm sorry
sorry I think you need to remember there
was a um I was prompted to mention
something that was helping me to make
Clarity on another Point you're now like
going in this spiral Rabbit Hole I'm not
I'm just I'm just trying to sorry babe
sorry okay it's not don't don't think
I'm you know I'm high I'm willing to
talk to you like you're not because I
just asked you how old yours I've signed
a contract where sir it's not edited so
I'm saying respectfully I don't mind
sitting off camera with you
like I began the story with I would sit
down with Sarah and speak openly I
really don't appreciate like the point
but the point he's making is like I
wouldn't say I was young and then get
mad when someone said how young I didn't
get mad
I'm saying like that that's the point
because I don't know the I can't I've
got really really bad PTSD
um years and stuff if I go to the doctor
and they ask me what what year was this
operation what not I can't give the
exact year if I'm on camera now and I
say it was 2000 and whatever and then
it's not I don't you understand it's not
that there's any disingenuous if you
want me to Emily I hear you but it's
like but even when you say this is like
you don't remember what it's just like
it's just you brought up the story I
didn't make you bring it up and then so
and so I'm saying it's just it gets
confusing when you you bring up a story
and then we ask questions and you're
like oh no I keep you know no I I'm just
telling you how it comes across I don't
know you because I know my reasons for
not wanting to say the year I will
Instagram him now and ask what year did
I get with you okay like I don't
understand what so you're going to do
that what's so proud
so you've together for three years did
you so did you celebrate any birthdays
together you must remember one birthday
you celebrated so just whatever whatever
birthday you celebrate that's how old
you was count back and that's it so I'm
not asking you how the only reason why
I'm saying it is because a lot of times
women come up here and say I'm young
this happens the whole Point's been
missed no no no no no I don't even
remember okay this cake like okay
basically sharing stuff Emily Emily
Emily what I'm trying to say is yeah a
lot of times people come up on here and
they say I was young and they try to use
an excuse me okay cool but then we asked
you how old you was you you negate to
tell us fine but at what point when is
when are you responsible as an adult if
you're talking 16 okay wait if you're
talking 16 we'll talk young if you're
talking 18 potentially it's before it's
like one of my first boyfriends so I so
you're talking 13. I've yeah I
unfortunately been in 13.
one at a time guys I'm not I'm not um I
don't have anything to hide in terms of
my relationship I'm pretty open like
I've been doing podcasts about sex and
relationships and whatnot I'm open I'm
an open book you don't know me from Adam
but I'm I'm I I live in my truth the the
ugly there's a lot of ugly and I can't
even remember the point of why I even
brought up that moment of my life
because it's just been like
I feel like we've just gone down a
rabbit hole Yeah like it's weird
well with that being said
um I was I actually have a video that I
wanted to show oh yeah go for it but I'm
gonna do super chats yes watching your
call at the video though right okay so
um okay guys thank you guys so much for
the super chats blessing is gonna get an
8K camera semi soon yeah yeah I told her
I told them you could order it this week
so all the super chats are going towards
a camera
um also guys don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to the channel we
want to get to 600k in the next week and
uh we'd like to get to a million before
January I know that's a crazy goal so
we'll see if we get there but you never
know
um okay also guys uh make sure you sign
up for our memberships if you want to be
a part of the chat today
um okay so our first and on the top
Super chatter is going to get if you
have a message
um we're gonna put like either a
whiteboard or a sign behind me next show
and then if you have something like
funny you want to write or whatever
we'll we'll put it up in your username
okay
um John teal and this is why men um this
is why men that can go for what younger
women do um numero cookie Monster ate
the accountability cookie and forgot her
age now she sounds like Charlie Brown's
teacher to me give us an age range at
least um John like unaccountable women
can't tell the full story
um John teal only trauma man in the 80
have come for the lotion
um the UK economists don't men don't
worry your soulmate is out there but at
the moment she's living her best life
with Chad and Tyrone
um Dustin Denton just oh 500 Super Chat
let's go stream sponsor Dustin Dutton
just keep going girl Nicholas Cornelius
I'd like to hear a discussion on the
Outlook of modern women on the parallel
to the dark Tria Triad traits on a
social level roots and narcissism and
self-important in psychop psychop oh um
psychopath
um make oh that's actually a good idea
for a show maybe NSX um welcome back
Pearl you left blue pills checking
themselves into therapy all across the
U.S mgtow by Logic No it's women that
won't trust not men men trust women all
the time and they establish in the back
women file for divorce 70 to 90 percent
of the time and women quit on us all the
time due to fomo and trying to Monkey
Branch Doug MPA cookie Cookie Monster is
a combative foreign for combative for no
reason women women don't build men up if
they average marriage ages 31 they are
there are two good men in the room
listen
Maggie The Substitute Teacher I can't
wait to see you on tlla's Mastermind he
did milk me for a date the other day I
am doing that um silly sausage don't
gain weight it's selfish you brought a
Ferrari brand new and you gave itself
four flat tires and turned itself into a
minivan and then you wouldn't let you
drive you'd be furious Mike Gardner I am
43 years old my wife's 24 we have very
different backgrounds to one another
from different cultures and races we
would love to be on your show and feel
like we have views to add to this
conversation
um I don't even know who to tell you to
DM right now keep bothering me till I
find someone
um John Telly okay no playing how about
a train I'm ldu lifestyle welcome back
Pearl thank you marriage causes divorce
I lost 70 percent in my UK divorce and
Lead attorney state of Georgia you can
lose 80 percent men routinely get
destroyed in divorce court it's not
worth it Gus if you're a single woman by
your late 20s and so on feminism has
lied to you and turned you into the
grown independent man you always wanted
to date and marry um Doug MPA China and
Sarah on the same stream Let's Go and
Let me refresh it real quick I think
that's all of them though let me refresh
um also guys like the video don't forget
Jonathan Lake now she's got PT now she's
got ptst PTSD be responsible
um when it's getting touchy um blue
bomber
um shuffling hard it's it's not me it's
super chats I'm Mark hedigo a need to be
right is almost always the need to re
need to control the narrative women
don't understand I'm allowed to disagree
mgtow by Logic this is a common tactic
women use which they never when it comes
to Grape when it which they never
reported to the police in order to
derail the entire topic of the show are
Trad relationships Dead who knows
um John then this is the okay so I have
a
video that I'm going to show you because
the original topic is we're talking
about traditional relationships yes so
that's that's the actual topic of the
show so
um we have a video um shout out to coach
Greg Adams
um you know you just like name dropping
here now yeah yeah um this is from he
was on sauce cast with Hafiz and um
Hafiz that name rings a bell for some
reason I don't look at it like do you
know her face you know I do I've heard
of him
um you know we worked together you
worked together once you know I don't
know what's going on with his channel
and what's been going on with these
videos it was a very interesting
conversation yeah yeah but this actually
isn't from me this is from his um he did
a collab with Coach Greg so if you want
to put that on the screen blessing
nice I want everybody to understand I'm
going to look into this camera right
here so I hope you see me really well
here I want everybody to understand and
remember that everything I say from this
point she backed it up all right so it's
basically zero all right you have no
hope no chance past the 20 years and
that comes from experience it also is
the experience you have no chance of
passing 20 years you're saying no no you
can pass 20 years and probably be
roommates and you'll probably be
overweight in a bus that Pillsbury
biscuit can or you'll probably be with
the exception to the rule but the data
shows us plus the experience that she
expressed that it's a very difficult
thing and this is what I want men to
know yeah it is very difficult many
people will simplify it for you they
will say oh just do this and do that and
they will lead you on a wild goose chase
and that's my perspective that's all
that I offer I tell men to not get
married especially when you don't have
leverage however I also tell you do not
listen to people who simplify this this
is a very complicated thing that most
people fail at misery
because you used a few things there yeah
about not getting married you said
sometimes you're trying to leverage okay
if you don't have leverage we'll talk
about that yeah and you talk about
turning into roommates well this guy is
the roommate the host of The Roommate
channel right
um when you're hearing this you've been
married one year and by the way this
guy's a sharp and formed very
intentional guy he's my assumption is he
didn't just trip and fall into marriage
he's seen myself before okay gotcha so
you've been you've been very you're a
calculated dude okay so when you're
hearing Greg say this yeah and even when
you're hearing Ali say this how are you
processing this information this is
really good and I'm excited about how
this conversation can developed because
I think you've maybe did you react to me
in ams's conversation a couple years ago
about marriage I didn't react to it I
didn't do reaction video but yeah I made
a comment about okay you made a comment
about it okay so um so to me I'm really
excited about it but it's also key to
talk about experience experience shapes
review right yeah so a girl who's been
abused by a lot of different men she's
gonna have a very sin clinical leading
view towards men a man who's been
cheated by business partners will be a
very cynical view about having potential
business partners so it's also unique to
talk about where does my yet we have to
be honest yeah nobody here is a hundred
percent objective that's one of my
arguments always with red pill stuff
they said they're speaking of Truth and
you're not a robot you know you're you
have your biases right call it for what
it is we all have our biases I have
biases you have biases coach has biases
as much as we think we are we have to be
100 honest to the people about our
biases if I'm an individual and I was
divorced and I had a difficult
experience via marriage I'm gonna have a
biased opinion via marriage
um Ali has a positive experience with
marriage so she can have a bias towards
well great marriages can work right so
see similar to me the people I admired
the most the people I look up to are
married People Patrick David Jordan
Peterson my father Pastor Mark Driscoll
people who I look up to the most right
long-term marriages the people that I
saw celebrate a lot long-term marriages
my father and mother been married for
over 30 years great healthy marriage so
that's my opinion my pastor Pastor Heidi
Lewis been married over 25 years so I
that's my world view and so to me
hearing what he's saying sharing there
is truth in that everything where
everyone's going to share it's gonna be
truth in it yes if you like my dad told
me a very powerful boy I love my father
he's so such a wise older man he said
the most important decision you'll ever
make in your life is the one you marry
and it can and it can go one of two ways
and this is the this is what I want the
guys to understand we're not teaching
naivete which is oh marriage is perfect
thing and you just meet the one and live
happily ever after and there's no issues
there's no divorces that's we're not
teaching naivete marriage can be the
worst thing in your life it can be an
absolute living hell and I guarantee you
you can go for days and for days and you
know so many different stories about
people with marriage is an absolute
living hell but we don't want to teach
being naive about the realities but also
we don't want to teach nihilism right
the other end of the extreme marriage is
the worst thing possible and women are
out to get your money and everyone's
miserable and everybody's roommates and
everybody is this because there are some
individuals such as what Alex
communicated who are in happy healthy
long-term marriage right so you don't
want to be naive you want to be
nihilistic you want to be as real as
possible give me the good the bad and
ugly and my biggest thing is that I
understand that marriage is a very
difficult thing to get right and and the
same thing is like I love how what you
do is marriage and money right I think
we're gonna be talking about those two
things today Adam you're a one percent
man financially right that means 99 of
people are trying to get to where Adam
is most people live paycheck to paycheck
they're struggling their lives suck when
it comes to money most people are
struggling but they're trying to get
where to where you are that's how I view
relationships most people are in really
sucky relationship most people it's a
day-to-day War hell the way work is the
way the gym is but then there are some
people who are having it at the highest
of level the same way we don't nobody
says oh well most people are not going
to be in the one percent so it's true it
you should even try it's oh my oh yeah
you know 90 of businesses ending in in
10 years you should even try we say if
somebody's gonna succeed why not use
which I love what you're doing if
someone's going to be rich why not you
if someone's gonna make money why not
you someone could have a great podcast
why not you so for me I acknowledge that
that the top of the mountain is rare I
acknowledge that but what I also
acknowledge is that if somebody's gonna
win why why not it be you and how can we
help as many men as possible get there
everybody won't be able to get there but
how many people how many people can we
help get there and that's what to me
matters the most strange I love that now
when you hear some
jeez
first of all right
I said wait till the other guy responds
oh okay go on there's just one more part
hold on like this obviously he's sort of
saying all right I hear you coach your
marriage didn't work you got out you
know thank God before the 10-year Mark
so you'd probably be a little bit more
spiteful than you are not saying that
you're spiteful but you'll be even more
spiteful if you're paying a ridiculous
amount of alimony and everything you've
been paying but is there anything wrong
with it if he's saying he's basically
saying I hear you coach It Ain't Easy
out there brother like life's tough
marriage is tough getting making money
is tough things are tough but don't tell
me that I shouldn't get married or don't
tell me that I can't have a successful
marriage how do you process that I don't
think anyone said
I think they caution people to say do
not get married if I say do not get
married without leverage that is a
position right that you can change thus
if you read my book it says once you get
to that position you can then make the
decision you'll probably come out better
yeah than going in it without it however
this is what I will always say when men
do find that that solution does not work
out
they are left alone
there's nobody to help them so people
encourage people hey why not give it a
try but when you go bankrupt when you
lose your kids when your kids are taken
from you when the courts kind of punish
you for making this decision or punish
you punishes you for being a slightly
better higher earner then nobody's there
with information nobody's there with
context no one's there to help them and
I believe not feel I know understand
believe and I have evidence to show that
men are left alone when they don't
succeed in this endeavor and that is the
void that I feel because I can tell you
hey men are alone in this situation men
are homeless men are thinking about
eating guns men are thinking about they
have no way out men are losing big time
and we're losing a fraction of men
through due to manipulation due to
people trying to you know they may be
heard a woman might be hurting a
marriage or she might feel that she's
not being appreciated and then she
throws a grenade in the room what
happens then see that's where where I
come in I get to show you what happens
when the grenade is there and I also
encourage you you're not alone in this a
lot of people come to my content and
they find out oh you too see before as I
said 70 years ago 40 years ago 30 years
ago there was nobody presenting this
side of the art this side I see what
you're saying right here nobody they
just left me alone that said well you
must not have been hitting it right or
you must not have loved it right or you
must have abused the kids that's what
she said she said that you were and
nobody came to this position so I
listened there was a void open and I ran
right yeah so if you okay
geez yeah can I first say that
Hafeez knows how to speak
without saying a lot
first of all
um but gone what did you want to ask
after that I wanted to see what you guys
what'd you guys think of that clip
um were you paying attention China
was on his phone
why are you holding me up for
you what would you think yeah it was
good it was good what'd you like about
it
I think there's quite a lot of
information to take in but I think the
guy the black guy in the suit we're
getting a suit on in the middle I think
he had a lot of valid points and it goes
back to choice you choose to be I think
it's a certain type of person that
chooses to be
married or the traditional way of living
when I think of like my parents or my
auntie's uncles they got married without
21 or 24. whatever
the start yeah I can look at differently
so I know my Auntie and Uncle are give
them as an example yeah they look and
act like they are still in love with
each other all the time okay it's a it's
a very nice unit
and
but then there's other examples I have
that it doesn't necessarily that's
something that you aspire to what to
have that type of relationship I used to
growing up I feel like as a girl you
kind of get taught this um fairy tale
way of Love or fairy tale way of being
like you you get married you have kids
you do this you do that and I did really
Aspire for marriage I would like to get
married one day but it's not now like if
it doesn't happen it's the end of my
life if that makes sense so if you you
said you'd want to get married and if
you don't it's not the end of end of the
world
um
why do you think that changed
um
you kind of wake up when you get into
real life and adulthood and you see how
relationships work does happen like when
I go think about the type of person I am
how relationships work and you have to
see through The Good the Bad and the
Ugly people change things change Money
Changes how you your parents might
change you might get into an accident
certain things that you have to want to
love on that person regardless of what
happens is deeper than just the day and
I think growing up you just see the
wedding dress you think I'm gonna invite
all my girls we're going to do this we
do that but after that point it's you
and that person do you get what I'm
saying yeah that because for me I
personally believe that
one of the reasons why the divorce rate
is so high at all what oh the reason why
women are the ones initiating divorces
because like you said they were sold a
Hollywood version yeah of what
relationship was and so what happens is
when they actually get into it they
realize that it's actually not what
they've been sold because women are kind
of grown on Disney movies and
rom-coms right and they believe that
relationships should be a certain way
and then what happens is when they get
into them they realize that it's
actually work do you know what I mean
like relationships are actually working
and so I feel like
to quote I feel like I feel like women
don't understand what relationships
actually are
yeah but Sarah who's who sold them this
because Hollywood did yeah but so when I
look so when playing demand so when
we're talking about it I'm thinking
about
um our demographic I'm thinking about
obviously our community that's what I'm
thinking about yeah when did we ever
prescribe to Hollywood selling us this
this white wedding and this and this um
this Prince Charming fairy tale like I
don't I don't understand where it's come
from because it's not something because
we're consumers okay so and we are
probably one of the biggest consumers so
we consume a lot of things we consume
and women are one of the biggest
consumers and debt consumers yeah so
many we we spend more even though we
make less we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so roughly 10K
less so I've always said never
underestimate the ability to sell a
woman a dream no I would like women get
Soul dreams on a daily basis like they
watch
um the Kardashians they watch Jay-Z and
Beyonce they watch Sierra they watch
Rihanna and they continuously dream
because he was saying In that clip right
about Hafiz was saying about oh one
percent and there's a 99 and it's like
for me he was having very
um female talking points if I'm totally
honest yeah I like Tony mentioned
Patrick but David that's someone that
obviously that that I follow on social
media and obviously I like the way he's
set up and he talks about how he came
from obviously Iran and Captain America
and doing all the different things in
his family unit so I understand what you
guys are saying about how danger it is
for men but I'm just still talking from
a point of where I have okay so in my
friendship group minimum amount of
people that are married but the ones
that are the ones that are their
relationships are strong and you can see
why they they married and obviously
they've got their kids together and the
family and then but the ones that
haven't the amount of dysfunction
already that is there it's like it is
that was there even before before
anything else so when I'm looking at
what I see personally
um so would you would on looking at that
clip would you be on do you think you'd
be on the side of her fees or coach Greg
Adams no so
um
does he want to talk about Patrick by
David and that talking about still he
was the one in the suit yeah who's the
one advocated yeah yeah yeah so him
you'd be yeah because I I just
I know it's a risk everything that you
guys say it makes sense like I'm not
stupid like it all makes sense but at
some point I'm still willing to put that
risk up like I could be one of those
people that could be saying little
nothing like oh man don't do what I did
I was foolish but at the same time I
would still say I put that risk out and
I went out there because what I've seen
in my life what happens by having a
strong family unit and a good woman in
your life in actual fact you do way more
coming from my sisters being those types
of women coming from my mum being that
type of woman how old are your sisters
uh this my younger sister is 33 and then
they go up got from that age yeah okay
yeah so
um like growing up from what I've seen
with my sisters and obviously not just
my sisters my family like the ones
around and like yeah I've seen more
dysfunction in people that haven't been
been married and and I also think it's
the type of girl that you marry as well
right there's some girls that that's
what they were saying yeah so I think
there's some girls that marrying is a
come up for them like it's a it's a
dream you know like it was so far away
from them for for out of their league
and then you'll pick them and you're
chosen to get married and you're chosen
to yeah but you can't you can't find a
girl that's not going to be influenced
by the culture no and so you can't you
can't take away social media you can't
take away TV you can't take away any of
that I'm not saying to take it away but
I'm just saying end of the day is like a
lot so like I'm saying women are roll
the dice yeah women women women are
master manipulator in general no I'm not
just I'm not disputing I'm so demand I I
think men in this Society are less
manipulated by the social media or
they're less manipulated by women are
addicted to social media men are
addicted to video games right exactly
yeah like we'll complain always on video
games okay what's your screen time yeah
and so if if men are being influenced
generally by computer games and women
are being influenced generally by social
media and they both come together right
my thing is online gaming no
we speak about traditional relationships
you know I mean we have these shows but
if the generations are not even both of
them both men and women are not even
looking to be traditional like the men
are I've always said men have lost their
purpose young boys are engrossed in
computer games young women are engrossed
in social media and corn yeah computer
games and corn that's what young men are
engross in women are engrossed in
um social media and corn also as a
matter of fact right so what happens
when you come together this is why I'm
talking about additional
um our traditional relationships dead
because I don't think either side
understand what it is to be in a
traditional relationship I'm curious
from YouTube what did you guys think of
the clip
I don't really have much to say about
the clip because I was listening to it
but not fully like it wasn't I wasn't
really focused okay for being honest
okay what about you same here to be
honest yeah so so are you guys on your
phones yeah yeah let's see there you go
social media
like are you Pro marriage like are you
Pro marriage or
your promise you don't want to get
married one day yes but it's just not
something that's in my foot right now
I'm like I've got many years to go until
I think about marriage what how are you
22 why would you say many years because
I just feel like I'm not where I want to
be in life like I'm not where I want to
be in life so I need to work on myself
get to that position and then I can more
focus on men but right now men it's not
my main focus because I've got things
that I need to do I'm not where I need
to be in life yet so if you if you were
to get a man do you think that you'd
know what a man wants in a woman
yeah because obviously I'd be dating
doesn't mean that I want to get into
relationships no but just at this moment
do you think you know what men want from
a woman right now yeah
not everything but most things
what name some stuff name three things
that you think men want from women
someone that's family orientated someone
that's ambitious
and
just someone who knows to show love and
affection is that a good enough answer
for you no I'm just saying like
um a lot of the time when women speak
the reason why I'm asking these
questions is it was quite probing is
because a lot of time women think they
know what men want and they actually
don't men don't care if you're in bed
they don't care I promise
I'm telling you I'm very ambitious I
work very hard like I put this whole
podcast they don't give a [ __ ] there's
no way you can struggle to get a man
like what's wrong with you nothing so so
I know so what you're what you're doing
is yeah you're you're judging women
you're judging men how you look at but
we don't actually so we don't care but
if you're ambitious you care for man's
ambitious yeah for us you have an
ambition doesn't doesn't make it what we
care about it's like a shoe collection
of a guy's a shoe collection you don't
care right yeah so that's that's what it
is to imagine like our work we care
about how you look we care about loyalty
um femininity and low body count that's
these are things that most men okay can
I just say something about the low body
count why do you care so much about a
woman's body Camp because you men you
can be like 20 and your body counts at
50 and you might get a good girl that's
only that only has a body count of two
and what like what are you doing because
because historically men had to ensure
paternity it's like we can't we have
biological reasons for the for the
reasons we feel the way we feel like
women like muscles and we like tall men
because we want a guy to protect us
right but men like a girl that hasn't
slept around because
um they could ensure paternity
historically because we didn't have
paternity tests in the old days but so
they can't undo that gut feeling they
get when they like they know you said
you say why this little potty cap now
have you watched the Maury show
yes yes right so you can't ask a man
like when you've seen that in real time
why do we prefer a low body count a
woman who probably has more of a high
body count is more likely like he said
to have a child that is not ours
right so that is all that that is that
is men's worst fear one of men's worst
fears is a child coming into the world
and we us believing that child is ours
and it's not or or it also signifies
loyalty right like okay would you say
what do you think women fall in love
through
like how do women fall in love would you
say
personality well me I see do you do you
think women fall in love through sex
come on
like do you think like the best the best
sex you've ever had
did you ever go back
um no never no
never
so I'll say why buddy let's see thinking
about it
but but the point is like like the more
guys you've been with like the more like
like I don't know there's just more
problems like there's more you're more
likely to cheat so so the reason the
reason you're 22 right and you want to
know why body counts so I'll give you a
bit of information and you should say it
no I'm gonna give you a bit information
about bodycon I'm not asking you for
your body crime I'm gonna tell you why
body Count's important but you sorry to
cut your channel but you said you don't
understand why men do you think bodycon
matters yes I think I do okay okay I
think you might as well I think a man
shouldn't really care too much
because no because nine times out of ten
your body count is higher than hers
anyways so like why do you care okay so
let me no that's not true so let's so
let me explain it right
in order for me to get sex in order for
um Sarah to get sex we need to have some
type of value about us we need to be
able to have something presented let's
just walk out on the street baby I'm not
like you man
so that includes having
um Finance being good looking being six
foot being basically having um
six Deuce baby basically having all the
things that women find attractive right
in order for us to sleep with high
quality women or any women and that's a
fact
um in order for you three women here to
sleep with with a man all you have to do
is basically say I want to sleep with
you and there'll be men that will want
to sleep with you so in order for you to
sleep with 100 100 men and and meet
asleep with 100 women is completely
different you could literally do this
and this is why a lot of the times women
think that men are having so much sex
because they equate it to what they can
get but that's not the truth of the
matter the truth of the matter is I'm
gonna have to take a girl out I'm gonna
have to three dates I'm about to do all
these types of things in order to have
sex but all you have to do is say I want
to have sex and a man will have sex and
that wait so I think can I just say
right like there's two women here right
yeah that are in um I'm gonna use this
as an England energy there's two women
here and you got hoodies on right women
can walk out on the street you women can
walk machine just hoodies and even your
Bonnet right and you can still go and
you can still Garner attention from it
you still men will still be like yo no
it's actually shocking it's actually
shocking but the thing is
men don't get that they don't get
afforded them if a man walks out looking
quote unquote bummy no one don't give a
damn do you get what I'm saying but
women can women can be mothers of five
children and go on the school run right
in their in their pajamas and men will
still holler yeah
men do not get afforded that same thing
one in three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year yeah so
it's not the most men aren't really
getting laid like that I think that it
goes back to what we were saying earlier
about what we see until we get told
these things that you know body count I
think when more people accept that men
and women are built differently we are
just we are gonna wait but definitely
genetically the way you guys just get up
and kind of put it in anywhere we know
as women
you know okay no way you know what I'm
saying
if you're doing that like that you kind
of have to look at you sideways because
it's a different experience for our
story we experience it's different and I
think for ages I used to get all funny
about the body count being because I
think oh yes nasty but not saying that
would be if somebody has had a million
bodies what do you mean it's not nasty I
don't know what the man said no yeah I'm
saying I used to be like oh man's got
too many bodies yeah but now I know how
many I have three brothers yeah so the
way men operate is different as a woman
when you're accepting of that
you see things differently what do you
want to say to you women don't want a
man without sexual experience that's the
only thing that's the thing same thing
exactly what I'm saying so the fact that
I would so the fact that right but the
thing is that's the difference between
men yeah that's it yeah men want a woman
who has a lower body count and would
prefer to teach her yeah right what sex
is women want a man to come to them and
know her body right and a man and a man
can't know your body unless he's had
sexy experience see when you come on
that God got three thousand one like
we're enjoying it but we're like where
did you learn that from the end of the
days you're supposed to learn no but
this is the thing
because we're enjoying it we're like
damn but we're like damn what did she
learn how many guys and then your brain
starts doing the whole thing so for us
men we don't prioritize sexual
experience as anything in actual fact
the less sexual experience you have the
better for us we don't look at we don't
look at you as sex as being something as
a selling point for women they think
they is but we don't for men you
actually look at it's like I want a man
that knows what what to do but for us we
don't actually want that so a lot of the
times when we're trying to speak to
we're trying to say like whoever's told
you this it's a fallacy it's a lie like
men don't do not prize sexual experience
when we're looking for women we look at
femininity we look at loyalty we look at
low body count some of these other
things
um obviously like
um family family oriented but not once
have we ever said you know what I want
to know know what I had techniques like
but there's a flip side to me go on let
me hear it we know that because the
reason why men go to strip clubs yeah
right there's a reason why men indulge
in corn right to such interesting
addicted to this degree is because they
fantasize about these women that can do
all of these things right we do we
fantasize about someone that can do all
of these things but then when we go into
our relationship we don't want a woman
like that because that's going to be our
wife but there's that
there's that okay if a woman can show
you sex experience and she can show you
all of these things we get turned on
this turned on by it so there is
literally there's a there's a bit of a
dichotomy there with men and I think I I
think a lot of women struggle to
understand that so we understand it as
men no I fully like like I fully hear
what you're saying and you're right and
I've heard women say oh but why'd you
guys like these like all these girls
pictures on Instagram yeah yeah you're
looking at you're looking at one night
versus a lifetime exactly so if you want
to be the girl for what there's so many
girls like the girl for one night you
know like they don't get the ring they
don't get the life they don't get none
of these things they just get the one
night they get the they get the
champagne bottles they get the sparklers
they get their back blown out and that's
it they might even get a bag from one of
these guys they don't get anything other
than that and at some point even those
girls want something more you know what
I'm trying to say to you so I think a
lot of the times it's just looking at
things from a different from a different
angle and that's why I agree with you a
lot but men we just want these things
for now not for a lifetime and you what
would you rather be a girl for now or go
for the lifetime so I've always said to
women like do you think that you can
differentiate
attention from men like do you
understand when a guy is looking at you
and is giving you attention because he
wants to [ __ ] you basically or can you
differentiate when a guy wants to
actually make you his long-term partner
like I think a lot of women say I think
a lot but I think a lot of women
struggle with that like they struggle
with differentiating between that type
of attention especially depend on the
setting and stuff as well yeah and yeah
I know that I agree and so what happens
is because it is a tension and women
lack attention they think a lot of the
guys that are trying to pursue them
which is why a lot of women think oh I
can back this type of guy because blah
blah blah no he will show you attention
because he wants to [ __ ] you but he's
not showing you the attention because he
wants to be of you long term and so a
lot of women have had attention from
guys who are of that top percentage
and they think oh I can bag me that guy
it's like no but he will [ __ ] you
and that is a hard pill to swallow for a
lot of women they don't get that they're
the woman that guys just want to [ __ ]
and they don't want to have a long-term
relationship with
do you know what I mean like there's a
lot of common dude there's someone for
everyone what I think there's someone
for everyone
how how when women make up 55 of the
population and there's more of Austin
yeah but yeah choices I genuinely think
someone's got to be the hookers
someone's gotta do I share numbers the
world's oldest profession someone's
gotta do it I never want someone I love
to do it but but someone will and
someone's got it but what you say is by
sheer numbers someone's gonna have to
share a man yeah because just if you
paid everybody up one one with each
other there's gonna be how many millions
of women on the sideline like yo but
what about me certain question for the
ladies you you have a guy six feet six
figures six inches would you share him
pay what more than six inches
what if it was like oh two as long as
I'm honest like living in the Mansion
yeah you know got the kids driving the
Bentley
see no email here no email I don't yeah
this phone
most people are actually doing that now
anyways it's not it's nothing new yeah
so then that goes back to the
traditional relationship are they dead
so you're saying as a woman you'd be
you'll be like okay oh cool I can share
it man that's not a traditional
relationship no but I would argue that
probably yeah way back yeah I was
arguing three ways yeah I would argue
like sorry it is a little bit even if
they didn't like what Pearl used to say
like they had you know they had whole
families across the road like they
didn't back in the day so they just
wasn't sorry only only 40 of um men have
reproduced historically all right it's
either 40 or 60 I can't remember off the
top of my head but there's a good
portion of men that have not reproduced
there's a reason why I'm asking this
because essentially I think traditional
relationships
are polygenous and polygamous I actually
think those are traditional
relationships that human beings have
engaged in since I think I think for a
small percentage Yeah I don't think like
by and large polit like that makes sense
for societies but I think it does make
sense for the small percentages I think
I think the Western world came in if you
there's a book called um out of Edom by
a guy called him uh Robert barash and he
and in that he shows that the majority
of humans
whether you go to Asia
Middle East Africa prior to the coming
of like the Western type of relationship
they were living in some kind of
polygamist or polygenous type
relationship and so if this new
um if this new type of one man and one
woman even though if you look at it
biblically there were certain people in
the Bible that had more than one you
know I mean if it's new
is it correct
but Sarah like how many how many people
share baby fathers now that's what I'm
trying to say like and they will
actively know let's see me personally
for girls got if girls got a kid I don't
touch her like that's just me personally
I don't I don't date women with kids I'm
not gonna be this step I just know I
just don't do that that's something I
won't do
um so would you mean for long term you
mean oh well at this stage I know you
had sex with a woman who's got children
let's be honest no no so that's not
dating like what what like if you want
to get your best you wouldn't touch her
that's why I was like you know what I'm
saying I'm like no no okay okay okay let
me um let me reiterate rap
I'm still not wouldn't now I wouldn't
touch up because I I just I don't once
you once I hear a kid that I leave that
for the guys with the kids and you know
I mean I'm sick I don't have any kids so
why am I gonna entertain a woman right
okay and that's and that's my thing and
and that's my thing but
if a woman had a child there's no way
I'll be saying by another man that you
know I'm gonna give you another child
but women will happily have a baby with
a guy that they know it's got a baby
mother two other baby mothers and a guy
that left his woman already like or left
or like like there's difference between
a lot a lot of times managers have
babies with girls and they just keep it
moving because he's in that top 20 yeah
but then he will still go and do that so
women always share baby fathers in that
because one guy will have one but that's
how women are always fighting with other
women over the man yeah so that polygamy
thing they do it whether or not they
they do it consciously they accept it
when they say you know what you've got a
kid I'm gonna attract you the moment a
man says to you he's got a kid you're
supposed to tell him to move on I don't
deal with you but you women will still
chat to him the moment you still chat to
him it's the moment you agree with it me
personally you got a kid now that's
never gonna happen because I know I'm
not gonna be a stepdad so you're saying
people with children should do with
people with children people without
children to do people without children
yeah like see blend and family that's
all good like if you got if I got a kid
you got a kid you get together you know
what I mean Brady Bunch whatever you
want to call it but personally if I come
out single I hate being out in in single
environments and meeting people with
kids because I'm like where's you like
why are you doing listen I don't I don't
disagree I think you know I I think
everyone should set their own standard
yeah do you know I mean like if you
don't want to do like if women don't
want to deal with me because I've got a
child
they're going to want to do no but
here's the thing they're going to want
to deal with you that's the and and this
is the real thing in real life right A
lot of times I don't know your situation
I don't know if they they're full time
with you
um but a lot of times is is I call
parents okay there's no benefits for us
being a stepfather I said this in the
last show so if I come into your home
and you have a daughter or you have a
son and you know I want to move in with
you if it was going to be me and you we
could have maybe just bought a one
bedroom it's good to go but now I need
to automatically buy a two bedroom
that's what that was having a child
right if you want to have my own child
we need to have a three bedroom so
automatically now there's a cost
incurred women always say that you know
what um it's not going to be your
responsibilities none of that but you
know if we live if the charge in my
house now it's under my provision so so
if you know if I if I took out mice
let's say we both have kids now and I
used an example before I take my kid out
to Fort Park you know and you got your
kid there if I buy my kid you know
McDonald's in there if I buy my if I go
and win my kids things and then your kid
wants something I said actually no go
and get your father to buy it you're
gonna have a problem with that but
that's what I mean automatically that
child's gonna become a cost if he goes
to school and if I decide that I want to
send my kid to private school because I
have the funds for it but I told your
kid not to send tell his father to do it
women gonna have a problem with it if I
decide I want to buy my kids Jordans but
I want to buy your kids some actually I
don't tell you and this is the thing man
the thing is I've been for it what
you're talking about I've actually lived
it if you have a daughter and then you
know the daughter grows up in the future
and she's and she makes an allegation
against me are you going to believe me
as the foot as the guy that's been in
the life for 10 15 or are you gonna
automatically think that's a these are
the things can I discipline your child
the way I want to if we break up our
mind I'm still gonna have access to all
of these things are just too many
variables for a man that hasn't got kids
to deal with when I can just meet a
woman and we're not going to have any of
these issues so I think a lot of times
when women are are single yes and
they're single mothers they love their
children I understand that they just
don't understand how much life we're
talking about a new contract would you
guys be
um open to dating a guy with kids
um ladies and for me personally I'm not
at this stage howdy
I'm 29.
um yeah I'm 29 um but it's do you have
children no I don't have any children
but it's more about what if I want if I
was to get into that situation it is
knowing that I would eventually become a
stepmom so I want to know that I'd be
able to like you said provide it
children are expensive like I have niece
and nephews I took them out a couple
days ago it's a lot it's a lot so I but
I'm not I just yeah at this point in
time I wouldn't get into it because I
feel like I'd then become part of the
year you know what's so funny
Every Woman breaks their rules for the
work for the right guy
yeah I'll take that sorry
all right so there's no woman on this
planet that can make me come and stepdad
bro no I'm not saying man no listen when
I hear that I'm like nah I don't give a
damn because I listen I know Rihanna
but every woman breaks their rules for
the right guy what about you two
um what'd you do to get with kids yes or
no
or in general sure I'm not sure leaning
more towards no at the minute no okay
I don't see a problem with dating a man
with kids because if he's treating me
better than the man that hasn't got any
kids I don't see the problem do you know
the thing I've noticed is that when as a
man if you can show a woman that you are
actually a good father yeah I'd like
that though it works in your favor so
when as I said when women say oh no I
wouldn't date a guy with kids you meet a
guy and you can say oh my God he's such
a great dad like you're gonna start
thinking but what about our child he'll
be like that and that's how women start
thinking they start thinking oh my God
history our child great yeah no that's
definitely a thing right that's what I'm
trying to say yeah but I still I still
don't do the kids
I thought about it there's nothing that
bad about it I just think like it's
easier when you don't
I I found that my parents relationship
is easier because they've only dated
each other and they've only had kids
with each other and I just think it's
easier when there's not X's around right
whether it's on his end or her end right
I think it's easier now we're in 2022
it's it's it's wild you know the average
average age of first marriage is 31 so
obviously people are going to have X's
but I just think the less baggage that
comes with and like that's you know I'm
going to read a statistic right yeah go
ahead
um this was reported by the national
um
uh is reported by Sky News by from the
national
um statistics on the in the UK so the
rate of marriages between men and women
fell to a record low in 2019 according
to figures from the office of national
statistics there were 18.6 marriages per
1000 unmarried men and 17.2 per 1000
unmarried women the lowest records since
it began in 1862 a total of
213
122 heterosexual couples tied the knot
in 2019 which is down 50 percent since
its peak in 1972 and the lowest since
1888.
people ain't getting married now
like people people don't even believe in
marriage and going back to what I said
earlier on as marriage being a joke
the people don't care about it
yeah but why would my so before listen
look before we had to fight we had to
fight slay dragons man we have to go you
know like we had to all it took was the
you know she would just drop late
dragons no but not this no with the
dragons at no but essentially we have to
duel me and you on on God like right
okay for the woman like we were going
the dad would send us on the quest like
this is what traditionally what men will
go and do just for the smell of a woman
and the virgin woman right now men don't
have to do that men just need a nice car
if that a rental and tender men just
need a good profile picture this got and
then essentially the standard has been
dropped so soon so women control the
standard if they required marriage in
order for us to have sex I think the
standard really has dropped though of
course it has I don't think so I think
women have higher standards than ever no
they have average men used to be able to
get average women they can't anymore
where it's it's for a small percentage
of men sure standards have dropped it
but for every other man standards are
definitely higher I think I think
women's expectations of Ohio but their
standards have dropped so the
expectations of what they want is for
themselves yeah but they don't they
don't settle 50 they're predicting that
50 of women will be single and childless
between the ages of 25 and 45. no they
don't settle off the chat and Tyrone
because they get mad so they don't
understand what the level is so that's
so but it's because the expectations are
so high if they actually was more
realistic about it they'll get better
results as long as you keep wanting the
same as long as 100 of women keep one of
the 20 20 of guys you're gonna still be
getting the bad results because it's the
expectations versus actually what your
real reality is Right women have always
wanted the 20 of guys always the
difference is now they have the option
not to do it no but I've got a
difference now is hypergamies on
steroids right now yeah yeah but then
you're going to get to the point of
where where you're gonna you're gonna do
all this for your 20s and if you don't
cash out if you don't select a guy
you're gonna get in your 30s and then
you're going to be competing with the
women in the 22s that don't mind
actually having a guy with a kid so now
automatically you're on your 30 saying I
don't want a guy with a kid then they've
got a girl that's in 22. I agree with
you I said she doesn't mind I I agree
with you but my point is that like I
think standards are higher than ever
before and that's why like that's why
there's so many shows based off of this
[ __ ] because you think in 1950 that the
women there were saying six feet six
figures six inches no they want to marry
Joe Joe down the block
it's harder than ever for men to get sex
the small percentage of men sure sure
the the good-looking men over six foot
with good job sure okay easy for them
most met like life is hard for most men
okay let's remove myself out of this for
a second so we'll remove ourselves out
because I'm thinking it from my
perspective right
but I would still say that that
expectations are higher and maybe their
standards are raised but what are you
what are your reality what do you get in
re in the real world your results and
the results don't match the expectations
or the standards that they play I've
always said that to him and I've said do
your do your expectations match your
results you said you want that guy or
that that that XYZ I'm like okay but do
your results match that and a lot of the
time they don't but they still want it
and which is why so many women as they
get older become are still single and
become in my personal point of view
bitter because they started making
expectations for themselves and
standards for themselves that they
wouldn't that that were never realistic
in the first place uh sorry I have a
question would you ever get married
oh in this current
this current version of marriage no
I I'm not gonna lie in this current the
way it's so heavily skewed towards women
I couldn't see myself what version of
marriage could you see I just told you I
got a whole contract though no I'm just
saying like it would have to be like I'm
kind of like and that's what I'm saying
it's because of the you would be with a
woman long term though oh of course
100 and you would love her right I want
to be very devoted and committed right
no but you probably would have a hard
time signing the contract because a
contract a contract does not favor me
and so I believe in love I believe in
companionship I believe in meant that
the union between men and women I
believe in all of that but that contract
that you asked me to sign I'm like I
don't know the problem is what are guys
like you supposed to do sure sure maybe
maybe you had a good experience of
marriage in your family but that's not
everyone like some people watch their
dad get taken to the cleaners right some
some men have like watched their dad
commit suicide some some men thought
that their their dad was a dead just to
find out he wasn't allowed in their life
after 20 years and so it's like what are
those guys supposed to do sign the same
contract they watched everyone else get
wrecked by I was in a 10-year
relationship
and it doesn't mean he doesn't love the
girl could have been classes of marriage
but even after going through that and
having the the isms and the schisms that
happen after that when you've got a
child with somebody etc etc I was like
imagine if I was married like I'm having
these problems without being married
imagine if I was married I'm curious how
long was it until the problem started
coming how would you say how many years
I would say six years in six years in I
would say about six years in would you
would you say there was like a switch
that was flipped or what did it do you
see signs early on I would say that I
could say looking back hindsight is 20
20. I would like ah you missed that yeah
you missed that oh you missed that
didn't you but because there's a whole
thing of when you're in a relationship
you're just in one and people from the
outside can see it which is very
interesting about love people from the
outside can say yeah I saw some things
and you're like no I love them I'm cool
everything's fine and that's what and
the thing is that's what essentially
what people are supposed to do in
relationships are not supposed to allow
people from the outside into there I
don't believe in allowing outside people
into your relationship
I don't believe that because I believe
that's one of the best ways for a
relationship to break down
so when you're in the relationship I get
why people say oh we were just in it and
it was happening and I didn't listen to
anybody else because I am I am a firm
believer that if I'm with you and you're
with me we should only listen to each
other because we are the ones in the
relationship no one else is in it it's
just us so I'm curious though don't you
think you would have seen it sooner had
you listened to other people I would
have seen it sooner if I had educated
myself better
that like I I can take full
responsibility and say there were
certain things that I did not know when
I entered that relationship there are
things that now I know after being out
of the relationship and so for me it's
it's growth as a human being it's like
sometimes you you do you have to grow
you have to go through certain
situations to understand exactly what it
is so I would say
because the reason why I would say no
because even my I'm a stubborn
individual I know that about myself it's
if somebody from the outside is telling
me you can't do or you shouldn't do I'm
like [ __ ] you imma do it like I know
that about myself so I have to look I
know that I have to learn the hard way
that's just me it's an individual but
once I learn I'm like
you're not going to fool me again I'm
not going to go through that again
because I'm also a learner so yeah
um if somebody from the outside could
have seen it would have been great if
they told me I probably still wouldn't
listen because I'm a hard-headed
individual so this is one of the
comments the reason it's six to seven
years is that's about how long women can
quote unquote live a lie before they
have it to unburden themselves with the
torture of the lie that they don't
actually want the man they're with
probably that's what I said the thing is
the things that I've learned as a man
and being in a relationship like that
for me are they're priceless
for me dude I'm just saying for me that
that absolutely Priceless would you do
it again hell no like I wouldn't because
I'm smarter now that's the thing I like
I'm smarter now so I've learned from the
mistakes that I made and and I've always
said
the only way a man becomes I say the
only way one of the ways that men become
men is going through tough times is
going through things that we don't think
we're gonna go through and we think
we're invincible and then life says haha
[ __ ] you [ __ ] here you go here's
a curveball right and I think that tough
times produce tough people
I think easy times produce soft people
so I would say that any man that's gone
through something tough in his life
he's probably like a man that people
would want to be around and and he's
speaking like that because he's gone
through those things
that's what I would say
love you Sarah oh [ __ ] I got some love I
got none yeah
um I'll take a second I'll read Super
Chat and then we'll roll yeah no problem
um okay guys all the super chats as you
already know we're trying to shoot an 8K
I told blessing he could order it when
he finishes our second reaction area
right blessing he's building that right
now
so we're almost there um make sure you
guys like the video um I believe we're
only at a thousand likes and we had 2
500 people in here so we should at least
be at 2K like so make sure you guys like
the video okay Anthony Cole shout out to
the crew I have statistics there are 164
million males and 167 million females in
the U.S alone if men historically dated
down and women date up who's settling
for who the UK Economist please ask your
guests if divorce laws were abolished do
you think women would choose more
average men to marry Oh that's oh that's
that's a good question a quick quick
because yes or no
if
they would you know there's an easy way
out right yeah what do you think yeah
yeah
I agree okay
um Jalen Montgomery can someone tell me
one way modern women make men's lives
easier when simple direct communication
turns to Advanced Linguistics why get
married as a Matic tell the blue
Teletubby to stop playing with her feet
that ratchet AF
um beach has they have some good points
on some issues but they really need to
stop using
they really need to stop using their
Google search law degrees the ignorance
is a lot on that first topic 90 Frito
pie
the appeal on corn is that they try
participate mgtow by Logic this is
actually a great show these modern um
fee fail guests are showing exactly why
Chad relationships are dead
um well done Pearl I see what you did
there 93 Tope that Hafiz show was awful
repeat the question because you don't
have an answer
um John Tully guy in the black he needs
a blue a blueberry flavor pill
um B Chas a 52 you the Bible doesn't own
marriage the concept outdates the Bible
people have been having ceremonies in
unions way before that ancient book 90
Frito pie what's the difference of
modern women's standards from an escort
and prostitutes back then both want
security and resources from high status
Alexander roof and shout out to coach uh
gang free agent lifestyle is the way to
go I will only get married when I move
to Thailand Philippines or Vietnam I
would never get married in the U.S a
Mike Gardner we love you bothering you
to find out the DM I'm Jonathan Lake now
she's got PS oh I read I read that one
already um Let me refresh it
Let me refresh it really quick now let
me just to make sure there aren't
anymore marriage causes divorce the
reason it's six to seven years is that
how long that's how long it takes to buy
a house and have two kids after this the
guy is a hundred percent getting
divorced um Anthony Cole shout out oh I
read that one okay
um so now we're going to close out the
show no problem let's close at the show
let's get people's final thoughts on
this show yeah any anything you want to
speak China
yeah like
traditional relationship traditional
marriages
um to me I still believe in them it's
what I was is what I was raised in is
what my siblings have it's what a lot of
my friends have as well even the ones
that that aren't married they might have
been long committed relationships just
without the contract like you said Sarah
um I think it's important for women to
to if they want to understand their
outcomes if they want these outcomes
that there's some certain things that I
need to go and do and into awesome stuff
I want a traditional man or a my
traditional woman or at least
in the new version of traditionalism you
know what I'm trying to say to you right
okay um and and I like for me this was
quite educational as well obviously
learning from some of the things that
you say and I understand it like like I
understand this whole contract without
marriage thing but it's just also how
I've been growing up so it's kind of
hard for me to conflict yeah like
because if that was the case in the
world I could have had a kid already by
now you know what I mean and I always
just think to myself any girl that would
have had a kid with before I just I just
really have no interest in them like I
just ask you you know what I mean like
what if you married him it's crazy
they'd have half
yeah but I would have see I would have
gone through that process to marry them
I would have thought about this and
there's a process before actually
getting married or you know but she's
just buying the ring Pro you know
putting that money down going to hat and
garden like like you said good and
that's where I would go hat and garden
and putting that money down it's a whole
process like there's a you know
arranging it doing I'm African stuff we
would do the traditional and the white
wedding so there's a whole process to go
if I didn't want to do this I would know
about it so imagine doing that and if
and it [ __ ] up I know I know but that
will be the L I'll take like that that's
just my L yeah it's not a money guy like
happy
because you can lose money right who
cares about money yeah but you can make
it more you can make it back and you can
just make it better but you can know
It's Only Money okay but no it's only
money here [ __ ] that you ain't taking my
money no no so you see the way we're
talking about it's like I want to get
ripped I don't want to get ripped bro
like that's not something that I want to
do but I also believe there's a certain
type of woman just like this certain
type of man that's going to look at
marriage and say I want that she doesn't
want to be outside here like in her 60s
trying to still trying to find man like
that's not what she wants to be doing
like because there's many people's
aunties that are still outside now with
no man you know what I'm saying and
they're acting like they're happy listen
no one's happy at 60 trying to look for
men like you're supposed to have kids
and grandkids and people around you if
you're still out no one's checking for
no badass six-year-old man trust me like
no man's checking for it some of them
young boy though you know but they're
just blowing your back out they're not
getting that yet and then you're going
to be financing them you're going to end
up going to the dumb dumb okay Dominican
Republic and getting young man in that
wow okay final thoughts
well when it comes to
um traditional marriage I don't really
as I said because I'm not really at that
place I don't really know if I believe
believe in it because I'm not really
thinking about it that much so there's
not much that I can say more on that
topic if I'm honest but if it was to
come to
um someone asking me if I believe that
in a relationship man or woman should go
50 50 I could you know speak more in
depth on that should they should they go
50 50.
well I believe personally if a man is
trying to get to know you he has to wow
you at first like you want to win the
prize I'm the prize
you think so once you've what yes why
are you depressed because if if the guy
wants me he's got to show me that he
don't want him no no but I'm saying he
has to show you interested yeah I know
but you don't you want him though yeah
yeah so why are you depressed because he
wants me like he wants me more than that
than him ah so you wanna oh so you want
to get with a guy who wants you more
than you want of course of course and
how do you think that turns out well in
the long term like if if you if he loves
you modern you love him do you think
you're more likely to leave
no because I could grow to love him more
I hate to be that guy that's like small
you know
and you think that's a right mindset to
have like to get a guy who loves you or
likes you more than you like him so you
want to be chased you want him to wow
you blah blah blah all that kind of
stuff and then what are you doing for
him once he's proven to me that he's
worthy of my energy then he'll be
getting the same energy right well all
right so this is great because this is
final thoughts but why why does he why
does he have to prove to you and you
don't have to prove to him
no I will prove to him who said I wasn't
going to prove to him I just want to see
that he's worthy of of me proving to him
and why are you so why are you so great
why are you so great like you say worthy
of me as if you're like this queen or
something like why are you talking like
everyone has their own different
personality everyone has their own like
I'm I'm probably like he probably sees
something in me that he doesn't see in
any other girl
okay so when I said and the reason I'm
sorry I'm sorry but I know why are you
guys laughing but I'm just trying to
like flesh it out and the reason why you
say that he probably sees something in
you doesn't need everybody
so so you see when I was saying that
most women choose like 20 of men right
do you think that he hasn't seen what
you've got is what you're saying like he
hasn't seen like in all his life he's
never seen someone like you well as I
said traits there's like different
traits that women have so maybe there's
something that he sees in me that he
hasn't seen another woman
I'd say this right
if you want something
and that's and that's something
has access to multiple things it's
probably best for you to study the thing
that you want and I for and I find that
a lot of women don't study men the men
that they want right because the men
that women generally want have access to
80 of women
but those women are telling these men oh
you chase me I'm the prize I'm this I'm
the but you have but you want that more
than he wants you and that's what you
don't realize because you're of the 80
he's the one that is in high demand and
if you don't study the thing that is in
high demand for you to get it then
you'll always lose so for me if I want a
woman and I know what women want I'll
study women
because I'm trying to get them the
problem is is that modern women don't
want to study men and understand how men
think and that's why you don't get it
you don't get what you want because
you're not because you're saying I'm
okay I'm just me if I just be me that
should be enough no you're supposed to
study the thing that you want understand
what that thing that you want once and
become the thing
that he wants and if you are doing that
you'll get the man that you want if you
ain't you ain't gonna get
does that make sense it makes a lot of
sense yeah so study the thing that you
want yeah
uh final thoughts
final thoughts yeah sorry
um just Emily music uh wishing you the
best in whatever relationship status
you're in traditional relationship
whatever it be
and um yeah rub your own feet it's good
for you
you know what I'm saying stay human
peace
and my final thoughts are that um I
think there is a new form of tradition
and you make your own Traditions with
that person that you wish to get married
to and I think when you have that
understanding with that person you're
good
that's it if you when my parents got
married there's a different town to now
when I'd get married so
yeah okay
my final thoughts is if you have watched
two or more tell them of our videos tell
them and you have not subscribed then we
have what Pearl beef what do we have
beef exactly so you better do that right
now go follow me Sarah Garvey on all
social medias
but but
okay I don't know what that was at the
end okay okay guys um make sure a couple
announcements before we end the show um
go subscribe to our two clips channels
Pearl daily and just pearly Clips also
guys like the video on your way out that
is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these videos in
the algorithm so if you'd like the
stream you enjoyed the show make sure
you like the video on top of that guys
um
make sure that you sign up for our four
membership tiers the first tier you get
to be a part of our chat second tier you
get to be a part of our Discord and our
behind the scenes Vlogs we're coming out
with a penthouse Vlog soon
um our third tier you get to connect
with me on social media that means you
have access to me like in the inbox so
if you have questions or whatever
I'll try to respond
um and she'll try Okay do you guys sound
weird Also if anyone sends me anything
weird on that tier I'm not responding
and you're not getting your money back
because that's weird now you know who
you are and fourth tier
um you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month and um if you want to know
how I got 67 million views this month
sign up for that tier because I got
secrets that you guys could find out so
like the video on your way out and I
will